happy Monday everybody hope you're not
having a case of the Mondays out there
sorry about that
hey guys welcome to the show it's uh May
1st
that's kind of nice May 1st coming
around summertime we love that
and uh welcome everybody
Shredder's having a case of the Mondays
welcome everybody thanks for joining us
for another fantastic week of shows
we've got planned here hopefully I'll be
getting digitally penetrated this week
do we have any leads on the digital
penetration yet or uh we do but you know
what I don't know if it's going to be
this week because the we found a very
strong lead uh but they're at a
conference until Wednesday
uh is it a okay cool I mean good he's
learning how to digitally penetrate uh
yeah hopefully um and the original plan
was to do it on Wednesday so I'll take
them when I can get him
yeah don't play that when he's doing it
though Zach that would be unprofessional
um we've got a great show here today
there's some juicy gossip involving our
brother at Arms Hassan [__]
Hassan let's get Aiden Ross's head on a
pike hiker
pull out you like that I don't know
and um Aiden Ross just a little piece of
[__] but like he's stooping the new lows
he's going after our boy so of course
we're gonna ride uh at dawn
uh in other news
this Thursday we don't have sponsors
this do we have sponsors again or this
week at all we do not today though uh
because we don't have sponsors I just
want to say Thursday
get your alarm set because my fawn way
collaboration with Teddy fresh my Funway
is this incredible
artist
is there a problem
should I stop or
hang on guys we're having technical uh
issues again
I don't know what's happening yet
[Music]
it's good okay
sorry guys there may be some I don't
know what some turbulence
as uh there's some kind of ghost in the
machine
is that how you describe it Dan he says
sure that's what happens when you have
Cutting Edge technology like us Dan's
frustrated but he's because he's a he's
working to fix it and he does he does
you know you know what it must be
Mercury's in retrograde until maybe is
it really yeah until May 14th so we're
gonna be doing oh that explains
everything I should just take the show
off of Mercury's and red sugar It's
gotta be that
um
the thing is uh we can stream from our
backup computer but if we do that I lose
the button and if I lose the button I
lose everything
so we're hopefully gonna get this worked
up but yeah my fun way is this really
amazing artist and this is a this is the
only shirt that didn't have a bunch of
green in it oh this one too she does
tie-dye amazing but the way she does it
is she does it in a big pool of water
and she paints these intricate beautiful
patterns and drawing in the water and
then she Lays
the fabric into it
so this is all painted on water as a
tie-dye and we have uh when this comes
out on Thursday we have a really cool
about the artist
article dropping that will show her
process and stuff
but I am very excited about this
collection it is beautiful
um
really really beautiful pieces
coming out this Thursday at 10 A.M PST
yep super nice so yeah there it is
also thank you to our members we love
you
all right so um
I went to the Renaissance Fair again on
Sunday
because I wanted to take
I wanted to see the back half of it
because the last time we only saw the
first half and Teddy's best friend came
hmm they were tearing it up man
but it was super crowded this Sunday
and then I was like well I did give it
like a glowing endorsement last week
yeah it's all because
he's Lily it is fun it was like packed
lots of nice Super Troopers out there
thank you everybody who came and said
hello
we love ya
how's your guys's weekend anything
interesting
it was good nothing just hung out at
home nothing too fancy
Lego building
really
what is there ever going to come a day
when you run out of Legos to build Zach
it's already happened
huh
so do you look for like um vintage Legos
I haven't gone down that hole it's just
more of a
like what's coming out next okay deep
inside the trenches you ordered some
just this morning right same day
delivery same day delivery yeah
oh that's exciting what what was it is
it a collabo well it's a Star Wars Day
on May 4th
um
but since I'm a VIP you know of course
you are uh you get May one access May
one on May 4th damn May the month be
with you exactly
so been doing that are you okay is the
Lego addiction becoming a serious
Financial strain on your family no no
not at all if it gets to that point then
no Moss
that's a lot of Legos probably yeah I
mean you do yeah you're fine yeah you
have Lego money
[Laughter]
good for you yeah
um you know on Friday we had this
absolute such a fun time was it on
Friday the Crowder video
uh it doesn't work for me either
Crowder was systemically destroyed by
not just me but like a lot of
conservatives too
and he's
promised us that he would drop a video
this week
and response
but today he posted a video and he's
just pretending like nothing happened I
mean Crowder what the f
look at this this man is seriously
posted from five hours ago six hours ago
he says
Epstein calendar released bro what are
you talking about
Epstein's calendar
the only calendar I want to see is
the one that says every other weekend
only for visitation rights for Crowder
nope that sounds like Epstein's gonna be
in a bikini like July and then August
calendar oh a calendar girl Epstein yeah
so he's just moving on like nothing's
Stephen hawkingham oh god dude stop it
prior to today this is I want I want to
just analyze his the tenor of his voice
here
because this man is not he is not okay
we talked with you about this because a
lot of people were saying hey you know
we signed up to Mud Club maybe you
didn't receive your mug at one point in
time or uh you weren't able to transfer
over or Reef we get it I've spoken with
a lot of you about this and Alex Jones
gonna be like pillow come up to me at
the garage and they're saying like hey
would I want to sign back up and I
already signed up only a few months ago
so
we don't he's not doing well
I can tell I saw lots of mugs being
smashed
we are trying to do our best to do right
by you so if you signed up for what did
you do bro you [__] up you didn't send
the mugs out what happened end up prior
to today this is something right now we
talked with you about
who's this [__] goon dude they keep
getting all these goons in the
leprechaun that's his dad I think that's
that's his dad yeah friend of the show
you're the [__] piece of [__] that
created this
uh yeah you did this bro this is your
fault everything happening right now is
your fault
oh I see the resemblance I see it your
fault it's your fault I see it now
oh man he's clinging to Daddy I love
that
your fault I work with Mom but I don't
trust women
I love Mom more
but I don't trust her I hate my [__]
dad but he's good at business [__]
watch it [__] watch it
yeah so Stephen Crowders this giant
scumbag and the comments are pretty good
Crowder needs to become a host worthy
host worthy starts with discipline and
respect watch it Stephen watch it very
good
Dave the leprechaun called it when
Crowder doesn't want to deal with
something he just ignores it
it's not about who was on Epstein's
plane Stephen it's about discipline and
respect okay that's fun that's that's
the meme coming out of this we should
probably pull that too then Zach you got
it
I see I'm not alone wanting him to
address this video with the wife big
mistake Stephen
what's the like ratio like on the video
so it is
um
it's it's pretty bad 52 000 down yeah
that does not work for me either can we
do a who does the better one because I
heard you all practicing it when I came
in it doesn't work for me either play
attack
that doesn't work either that doesn't
work either it doesn't work either
anyone else want to try nope that
doesn't work either it doesn't work
either either let me hear it
either it's pretty good thank you it
doesn't work either sounds like he's up
on the bema during his bar mitzvah and
his voice is cracking it doesn't work
for me either oh that was good Zack go
ahead go again that doesn't work for me
either that was good
it doesn't work either
ice is awesome yeah okay so his daddy
had to step in huh to make sure
everything runs okay Stephen I'd be
embarrassed if my dad was sitting here
with me like I mean come on grow up bro
it's time to be your own man
you know what I mean
daddy will you be cool daddy will you
come on the show today just to make sure
everything just to make sure that you
know I can get through it all right
and uh the live chat is gonna be really
mean today
[Music]
can you please watch the moderators on
the live chat Daddy
he goes son I'd rather not be on camera
that doesn't work for me either
wow look at these two losers a
generation of losers [__] watch it
[__] watch it
you this is all your fault dude
you goofy-faced you gave your son your
goofy face I see it do you see it
do you see it
did you see it uh these two [__] guys
[Laughter]
prior to today this is something right
now we talked with you about this
because we're saying hey you know
everybody's asking the only thing
everyone's asking about is where are our
mugs I have not received any other
questions
signed up to Mud Club maybe you didn't
receive your mug at one point in time or
uh you weren't able to bro are you
scamming your fans you're gonna take the
money not even send the goddamn mug
come on
that's fraud
um to be fair you probably can still
just legal team out how to handle it
honestly a level of transparency and
just genuine regret is what folks want
to see
I can't wait
that doesn't work either I'm gonna
ignore it with my dad
anyway
shout out to Stephen Crowder who is
a wife abusing piece of [__] and his dad
is also a piece of [__] I know where he
got it from
mm-hmm
that's right
I wonder what his dad said to him about
it because obviously he's heavily
involved
son I want to tell you
I would have handled that the same way
you did nothing wrong
women it's women's fault women son
it's not your fault it's your fault your
fault
yes so uh okay moving on
this was pretty funny post from the
subreddit over the weekend this person
thought they had a
hit a gold mine they said yo I caught a
Teddy fresh hoodie at the thrift store
but wait
oh no
oh no you got sister snatch why would
anybody donate this that is crazy sister
pretty great post though huh
maybe they were a fan before the
allegations [__]
[Music]
also Joe Brandon is out there making his
rounds at the White House Correspondents
Dinner just a little bit of a meme
um dark Brandon
is embracing dark Brandon and I don't
know how I feel about it I'm so mad I
don't think I like it that sucks dude
you ruined it
yeah hey let's watch the video Roy
opponent is yours
I'm gonna be fine with your jokes he's
made of wax I'm not sure about dark
Brandon
[Applause]
yeah so the people who told him to do
this should have had the meta awareness
to know that this would have ruined the
joke yeah because that what happens now
that dark Brandon's gone he loses a lot
you know it was all he really had that
was all the steam in his campaign to be
frank
so dark Brandon is over
hate to say it
she's also died
they're selling merch too I don't know
if we've talked about that on the show
The merch I was okay with because he
wasn't like directly involved yeah this
one he's sitting there he's putting
those glasses on his face you did that
for himself he did that
I like his young team coming out with
mugs I'm fine with that mm-hmm
uh here's a nice little thing again
Minnesota senator if you can believe
that this man is a senator
one of a hundred distinct
congressman
well this is the uh this is the
Minnesota Senate not like the oh it's
not a it's not a yeah it's like the
custom [__] bag [__] dummy
so they're voting they're doing some
State uh vote by zoom and our boy out
here he's like man I didn't give a [__]
about any of you
yes
Senator Barr
[Laughter]
he's got the conjunction Junction what's
my phone so my questions is did he mean
did he know his camera was on
probably nothing yeah right bro you're
in bed like it was a half tubing he
didn't go full tube and it was a half
tubing right right
stupid of course being the guy who got
caught jerking a corporate Zoom meeting
and he still works that's the best part
I mean he said he was sorry so yeah tug
off Cuban how do you show your face
around the office
I mean but here yes yes
representative Greenman yes yes
representative Anderson yes yes Senator
bar yes yes yes yes
well done guys
only the best and brightest represent us
people
and that's why representative democracy
is just infallible it's the way to go
thank you to
to uh
senator
Barr
excuse me my throat is my gird is acting
up
my throat's been all torn up man
uh Walter AKA coconuts and Barbados we
had a little bit of a tit for a Taff hit
and a half with them on Friday
and uh some fans came out with some
fantastic oh no no coconuts are divorced
yeah but I'm not actually getting
divorced like so it's not it doesn't
work yeah you are uh what was that uh uh
soon yeah
let's watch out yeah but wait till I'm
getting divorced because it doesn't make
any sense you're divorced no he's early
on the own I mean you could say that to
Crowder because he is getting divorced
right but not to me not yeah it doesn't
make sense but here is a here's somebody
put this together of uh him trying to
think of that joke it's an entire
economy built upon lying to women and
deceiving them because since women are
more impressionable and we talked about
that in the book too like how women hold
a majority of the debt they're consumers
in general so like if you if you're an
Advertiser or your marketing agency
women what are you gonna say you're not
gonna say stop being effective and being
annoying you're gonna say love your
curves
[Music]
yeah
he adds a lot of value to this show man
some Barbados you can really just what
was that uh quote again coconuts and
Barbados
[Music]
yeah he's crushing it man
he's the man crunching the numbers
really quick
he's the man we love coconuts in
Barbados wow yeah
I do love him and I think Olivia you had
a wise moment when you felt bad for him
because it's kind of sweet how dumb he
is thank you for saying that um yeah I
he hasn't said anything
period like he hasn't said anything to
the point where I cannot like him all he
said is coconuts and Barbados and
coconuts and divorce and I'm okay with
all of that he may disagree with
everything Myron says he could hasn't
voiced it yeah
he hasn't voiced a lot
we should get Walter on here I'm
straight up I would love to have Walter
Coleman I think we could have a really
Pleasant conversation I think so too he
seems kind
yeah um so shout out to coconuts
in Barbados
oh no no coconuts are divorced yeah but
wait till I'm getting divorced don't you
see it's not happening yet
uh
go on
uh what was that uh quote again
I don't know man
you got did you want to say something or
okay so he's he forgot he forgot he's
thinking
yeah when you think of that quote again
coconuts let me know okay but oh no no
coconuts are divorced okay okay okay you
got me
uh so um a fan actually sent this post
which was phenomenal this is from James
River Men's Conference this is a
conference for men
what state did this take place in
I gotta know oh uh is um
wait Missouri Missouri yeah I'm pretty
sure it's Missouri
so this is again a conference for men
this is a church event
this is sanctioned by Jesus Christ
this is the best use of money they've
Jesus has decided so here it is
all the men have come together and
that's quite a lot of men
what are we gonna do about these men
and what do men want to see what a men
of Christ want to see sex with men
[__] tanks crushing cars [__]
and rock and roll did this get claimed
did we say I did not yeah
[Applause]
yeah
oh my God
[Music]
yeah baby
this is a church event
[Music]
church event
yes baby yeah gee if only G's were here
boy
that's what I'm talking about brothers
[Music]
you don't see how unsafe this is they're
like okay slow down like this man could
just floor it [__] it
the danger zone everybody yeah baby are
you seeing how nobody in the crowd seems
to care
I see like zero movement or excitement
from the crowd I think they're all
filming they're all just a bunch of
white trash filming for Facebook they're
all filming they're all filming you see
that there's a I have another angle and
you can it's from the audience and it
does seem like people don't really care
for this it's not it might be the only
person who may be having fun is the dude
in the tank I mean that would be fun to
drive that spectator sport is not that
interesting yeah
and I gotta tell you this was not cheap
to put together oh no
no yeah baby the tank
we did it is he shooting blanks or you
think those are uh live ammunition those
are live rounds just like Jesus would
want
all right so you haven't come out like
this at our live show
um rent a tank to just burst through
just kill everybody in the audience go
just come through the wall
ah now that's an experience I'd be more
than happy to shred it up while you come
out even on the tank
no but legitimately I mean they had to
bring a tank into this Auditorium
six I mean they're junked cars but they
still cost money I mean insurance
Medics [__] because it costs to cost 100
grand for this worth every penny
how many sandwich you make for 100 grand
just curious
I'm not I'm not religious so
I got no problem spending on dumb [__]
but Jesus has rules for you dumbasses
that I don't have to follow them
Praise Jesus
[Music]
yes
Men's Conference we are not gay
look how masculine we are
nobody in here
so let me see that that second angle
monster truck tank flag lightning Josh
Hawley was there who's uh
one of the great [__] bag fundamental
Christian Congress people
here is from a different angle let's see
how excited they are
is this white trash um
who's the late night guy everyone hates
James
gonna see it
that's so sorry
let's go the tank
[Music]
uh again
a church event I I cannot you just have
to
pose the question to all of the
Christians out there
the warrior for God
this [__] badass
man oh Zach
oh Zach I'm glad you admit that at least
yeah I guess it's kind of cool sure I
mean he's crushing cars is cool I'm not
gonna say it's not it's the you got to
take the totality of what you're
witnessing in here and you got some
[__] hacked ass wannabe hair metal
band yeah and at this church event and
then the audience is just like
like all of it together is what's so
funny I'm not gonna deny it ain't
crushing a cars cool let me get a look
at the audience here
[Music]
[Laughter]
[__] yeah dude
let me do a slow-mo
so we can see
the true reaction
of the tank loving Christians
dude that's a little too slow
here we go
okay
so I think a lot of people are filming
but there is definitely a lot of um
unimpressed folks out there I mean
people should be on their feet screaming
like that's like the energy that they're
going for right now I mean this did
that's a dead audience I'd be
shotgunning beers man like I Stone Cold
Steve Austin they are all sitting their
white asses down and listening right now
the pyrotechnics that ain't cheap
that's what Jesus is all about man we're
receiving reports that that is a British
tank not an American Tank that's gay is
that's anti-American well that's why no
one cheered hold the [__] phone
okay British tank dude you may have
wasted a hundred thousand dollars
crushing tanks
you may have spit in the face of Jesus's
teachings
but I will not tolerate a British tank
rolling through this gear American
Church
I'll say it again Brothers
it's about time we declare war on them
English
and when the bombs drop
just know that Jesus signed his name
Lord on that torture
a British tank
yeah my dad my dad plays World of Tanks
that's a British tank dude Ohio loves
Dad what's your dad's name or if you're
comfortable yeah his name is Hawk Young
Fortune
[Music]
I'm sure you're pronouncing it correctly
yeah
foreign
we love our Swedish brothers and sisters
out there we love the sweets
love them where would we be without
Sweden not out to Sweden shout out to
Sweden uh here's Josh Hall Holly
speaking this guy is such a [__]
scumbag man
um
he's just one of those people a demon
is it one of those guys this is Josh
Holly here I am so wait his ass didn't
even show up no no he did it's just I
thought this promo was funny rewind it
to the beginning I want to point
something out right at the very
beginning of this video
what they're like promoing the Harlem
Globetrotters and I was like what the
[__] they had that Harlem Globetrotters
to come to this conference and I looked
it up and no they didn't
that's interesting stronger Men's
Conference Harlem Globetrotters I mean
couldn't find any reference to this
anywhere on the website
maybe maybe they did but they'd like I
don't know previous year weird yo they
set up a bull fighting ring in this
Auditorium these people are insane maybe
these are pre oh maybe previous years
the Harlem Globetrotters were there okay
dude what the [__] is this just go feed
some homeless people y'all want to go to
heaven or not
like seriously
hey man Josh Hawley here I am so excited
to be with you for stronger 2023 I have
loved going to this conference in years
past I'm super excited to be part of the
speaker lineup this year it is coming
really quick so get registered today and
I'll see you there
oh yeah dude wait by the way compared to
those other shows this was kind of the
worst one because it was like it lasts
like 10 seconds you pull the tank out
that's it the men need more meat than
that there was a hole so that that
second angle that I linked to I time
stamped it to the tank entrance but that
actually has the whole intro which uh as
love pointed out was extremely soy uh
throughout did not seem very manly to me
well they say it's the stronger every
year so they're getting there
they're still quite weak oh they're very
sorry we love we love a self-improvement
yeah okay but every year getting
stronger
here's the events yes
let's see stronger mint conference we
got to send someone to this info bran
when is this April wait it just happened
oh [__] so I gotta wait till next year
I'll add it to my list add a running
list of events that we want to send
people to right now yeah we need boots
on the ground yeah that'll be friends
that'd be awesome
I'll mag it up
[Music]
next year for sure you know it'll be
extra crazy because it's an election
year too oh my God it's gonna be so hype
120 bucks
not bad
it's fair priced
I
I'm actually surprised I thought there
would be a lot more than that
so yeah okay no here they you can
already buy tickets April 12 2024. oh
stronger I can reserve my seat now for
just 45 dollars down
good
yeah and if you're a student you get 10
bucks off so that's fire
hell yeah dude this is a high demand
event brother because so I heard it did
look packed in there so next week we got
a real showstopper boy we're gonna bring
out the Gallows and a bunch of them
immigrants
I'll tell you what boy
um
we're gonna have an old style execution
brothers that's right
instead of sending them immigrants to
Martha's Vineyard they sent him out here
to The Men's Conference we take care of
them real nice
mm-hmm
it's the means conference brother I'll
tell you what next year then be
immigrants sitting in them cars
ain't no Caravans coming this way boy
um
somebody in the chat asked if women are
allowed
did I [__] stutter Men's Conference
what are you stupid what it's typical of
a woman to ask oh such a woman question
no women are gay women don't like tanks
women are gay women are allowed to play
with tanks
right
just be my bro either you can't women
there it doesn't work
uh Stevie Crowder I love Stephen Crowder
for what he did for us he
you know he gave us he changed the game
in a way
so that's pretty fun watch it here's the
church James River Church
do you have
let me just see what's their like
mission statement
do you have a prayer request or a
testimony from what God has done in your
life we love to hear from you okay
prayer I'm just going to request a
prayer for myself
um
I'm not gonna put my Jeff Dunham
that's what I type in any
any name for him my whole life and I
don't want to put my real info I just
say Jeff Dunham and then I go Jeff
Dunham aol.com it's always at AOL.com
right address
please I'm not giving you that one two
three Street
uh which campus do you currently attend
west side
write your prayer request below would
you like someone to call and prayer with
you yeah uh oh yeah yeah hello yeah
should I put my number in here
um I'll take that call well take it off
the screen if you're gonna do that well
check what's the um no don't put your
number in there no not down for them to
see but what's the um
the uh two-party consent law in Missouri
is it a one or two parties Missouri a
one or two party consent state Missouri
uh that's one party babe that's what I'm
talking about
15 is the age of consent
hello I need a prayer Lord I need to
pray I need a prayer Lord thank you
Jesus
please call me back
my son should I do something like my kid
is thinks they're a girl my boy thinks
he's a girl let me pray help me pray on
that they that would be pretty good
because they called me for sure
they ring you right up my son thinks
he's a girl
Lord help me Jesus I cannot go on with
this gen Z
silly nonsense about gender and all that
them there
please call me ASAP so we can pray on
this my boy needs to be saved
his name is
please please would save him before he
becomes a Jennifer amen
all right you think they're gonna call
me does that seem real enough
the name Jeff Dunham might uh
well what is that people named Jeff
Dunham I'm putting in my real phone
number
oh my God I feel like a super alt-right
pipeline person would in the address
thing but I'm not telling you where I
live one two three straight yeah that's
the other thing I gotta change the
address maybe maybe but it feels genuine
I'm not telling you that day
come on the government is bugging I'm
just gonna write something in I have not
filled out a form in 35 years and I'm
not about to start now I'll tell you
what man Paper Trails are Satan's trails
all right I'm just gonna type like one
five seven three Wonder Lane Road
seems legit
uh uh City
state Missouri
they're in the Ozarks too if you wanna
we're in the O's how what's the the two
letter for Missouri
mrmo I believe MO
state
wait let me confirm that state code
that's not Montana
Mr okay it is ammo yep Mo a demo
Missouri
uh city what city am I what's that big
city there in Missouri St Louis St Louis
um
St Louis that's right I mean that's
right
I'm on the west side okay I'm submitting
this
the problem with your submission what
are the address isn't complete
[Music]
okay oh geez okay just can you just put
Kelpie pays me at random yeah just from
Missouri
looking at random oh Jesus please pray
with me
my son don't say it out loud obviously
when I no no no no no no
Heaven's done perfect
type this one in
I gotta open Discord here so hopefully
we'll be getting a call from the James
River Church group
and please I'm praying for a couple of
tickets to that Men's Conference
Lord Jesus
Discord is updating
excuse me I mean it wasn't it wasn't
open what the freak so here we go
um
I don't see it
sorry I covered it up with that super
chatter all right I just resent it
oh there's now that's a nice dress
mazura
I like that address rather right
mm-hmm
I like the town name too how do you say
that you could say the town name
uh
crave core
I crave Coors because that is that Bud
Light is all kinds of trans nonsense
zip postal code oh [__] this makes no
sense
come on yoki's figure your [__] out
that makes sense
all right
I think I got it let's try again this is
important I mean if we have a potential
to get a call in a prayer I think we
gotta go for it
[Music]
prayer requests submitted if this is an
ER there's this
there's a uh
there's a little message it says if this
is an urgent pastoral need please call
the church at this number
help me
okay well here let me um
you think they'll call like now
I assume they'd get back to you in a
couple days no no no no no
they probably just sold your number to
like a spouse
they definitely did that's why they
wanted the address [__] why'd I give my
real number
when did you say that before
well I thought that was obvious
we we looked into them before the show
too they're a Pentecostal denomination
which is the actual church that speaks
in tongues and [__] so they'll probably
on the phone with you I think they're
gonna call me within an hour Dan
that'd be epic you think they get a lot
of submissions
I don't know but the these I used to
print all these lines a lot and these
these people are on it these prayer
lines they're like
they have great customer service boy
well then I'm excited for them to help
us
the movement of the spirit of God
we kid our Christian friends we kid them
we kid the ones we love
yeah moving on Andrew Tate who
is boring and dumb I'm not even gonna
talk I'm not even really talking about
him it's just kind of funny Andrew Tate
and snico
have taken a new sponsor
and what is that sponsor
they're promoting waifu Watchers which
is a
2D anime wife waifu pillow
so this is goiper [__] I guess this is
like they're actually selling this
and again if you are telling men like
how to get laid or whatever okay
this is a great one step one don't have
this in your room yeah
especially if it's like because these
people they don't even have a sense of
humor like this if you have it in
because you're being funny or silly but
these dudes are like no
I'm dead serious
I'm dead [__] serious about this oh
you know and how are you not embarrassed
to uh promote this I don't know
must be more desperate for money than we
thought
um here's wafu Watchers with Andrew Tate
this is the guy who made it
and I just gotta say yeah maybe they're
desperate for money
uh anime waifus are better than real
girls he says
I guess that's the ultimate Blackville
if I can't get a real girl I'm gonna put
a hole in my waifu pillow
fill that up like
fill that bag up
like semen at a bat like a seaman at a
background Ziploc
so they continue to be the coolest most
Suave dudes who totally understand women
so congratulations to um
snico and Andrew Tate for this fantastic
uh
partnership they've got
liver King continues to be a fraud
I get I think my theory on liver King is
that he's back on the roids I don't
think he changed I think he saw that his
body was shrinking and he couldn't deal
with it and he's back on it because his
body has not changed at all
and he's still out here doing phony
baloney stuff
watch the fish he's just shaking it with
his hand it's so fake the fish is
obviously already dead
holy [__]
[__] it stops moving when he bites it
and so this is I mean who are you
kidding
it says it's believable of as you being
sober bro
is having for dinner today the [__] is
this boat I just can't believe like are
you recording I got I just got this out
of the lake oh my God so we're having
fish
called shrimp Primal rice prawns we got
Raw Liver raw testicle rubber with
breakfast lunch dinner because liver is
good I just can't believe you oh my God
he's roided the [__] out of his mind
look at his body yeah he is come on
liver again how are you gonna milk an
oat
he relapsed dude he relapsed yeah
and you know he reached out to me
unprompted he says I want to come on the
show again and talk about the real liver
king I said great
and then he he ghosted us kind of like
the first time
right we reached out to his people and
uh called his manager probably about
three times and he won't return a phone
call yeah
well maybe they realize that we've been
making fun of him the entire time yeah
maybe
so we finally woke up to that
this is gonna go viral am I I'll come
blue this is gonna go viral
um get yourself
but it's fake right like every does
everyone know that it's fake when I
first saw it I thought it was real every
single comment so the thing is I just
wasn't paying attention it does look
[__] is up with it it does look real but
then when you realize he's just shaking
his hand and then when he goes to bite
it the fish completely stops moving no
when someone said something yeah I
noticed right away he's obviously just
moving his hand oh my God
you see it's like oh it's dead now
okay whatever bro nobody cares
lameo doesn't even eat it subprimal
Behavior am I I can't believe that I bit
the [__] um also the shrimp
yourself
with breakfast lunch with a coward
you're not gonna eat raw seafood you
[__] coward it looks kind of sauteed in
like a garlic mince or something you're
right oh yeah that's cooked l l yeah I'm
recording I'm a [__] dude eat raw
shrimp like a real man yes
uh
uh okay so the comments are
[Music]
real pulled a ribbon fish out of
freshwater lake oh so it's not even a
freshwater fish no that's funny uh oh he
got on the wrong side of uh fish talk uh
uh uh there's weights in those fish
people are saying this should affect
your credit score
I don't think anyone's buying it yeah
all right liver King do whatever you do
man just you know what I mean
I know he's being sued though I wonder
how that's going
about lying about being on steroids
right well I'll probably take years to
get elitigated right well them the
Motions would be filed within
hmm
a few months I would assume yeah
um here we have a guy
who's giving Mobility Mary energy in New
York City
flying around on a bike now New York
City is pretty wild there's a lot of
pedestrians
and the bike lane is known for not being
very good because there's just a lot of
people walking around all the time and
frankly I wouldn't assume
that my bike lane experience is going to
be great there but this guy expects
nothing but Perfection here he goes
never caution but let's block it with
stupid signs
I guess we don't know how Pine Place
work it's a great place to stand
hello
it's a great place to stand
very good
sidewalks over there genius it's
sidewalks over there genius
you're the smart one
hey okay well don't just don't kill
yourself bro like slow down
right
mirrors wait
they were signaling weren't they I mean
I I yeah I'm not even entirely sure that
that was their fault yeah I think they
have the right away just slow down also
you'll die so like just give them right
I mean whether whether you're in the
right or not yeah they had their turn
signal on
I mean they have to turn
this man will die out of space
right put the phone away oh come on the
phone
now you're just hating on other bikers
who don't meet your purity test I I have
a lot of sympathy for bikers because I I
think it's you know I think it's good
that people bike instead of causing more
traffic with cars and everything
um
but yeah this guy seems a little
a little high strung I guess you could
say I remember Casey neistat made a uh
bike lane video where he uh there was
always [__] in the path and he would
just ran through it and he kept eating
[__] yeah funny video
didn't have this whole no not at all put
the phone away he's one of your own he's
one of your own man
foreign
blocking the bike lane
it's a little Block it's just a little
yeah
I made a chance to Cali people don't
understand yeah we don't have bicycles
in California you're right Nobody Rides
bikes here
idiot I mean come on
you got there okay all right he's gonna
get his [__] rocked in the middle of the
street when there's a sidewalk on the
left so okay I guess I I would imagine
the audience would be split on this I
used to bike in Boston and it's pretty
similar sister City to New York I guess
and like I don't know I would never
scream at people like that but it's it's
very annoying wrong way idiot so maybe
he's just doing what what all the bikers
wish they would do I think so yeah he's
just histrionic here's another one
idiot
I just want to explain how bike Lanes
work
he's got a couple lines in his
repertoire I noticed
it's like an NPC
yeah
as I made the turn my plan was to pass
on the left
literally half a second and I realized
he slammed on the brakes okay bro that
was your fault you were following way
too close
don't try to blame him
[Music]
where's the bike lane brother
my knee caught the bumper and my head I
kept telling myself stand up you can't
be hurt
he's like a war scene
stand up you can't be hurt
I do love him though there's a Mobility
merry quality
sure most of these he's in the right
but yeah like I said it's just when you
see the compilation
it's a bit much okay if he takes
responsibility then this is a dub in my
mind he's he's good let's see how he
handles this
morning
you okay
hold a piece of plastic out of my legs I
gotta tell you I hate the [__]
I think
you're not alone bro I expect you to
stop dude I I have to stop I got I don't
want to run nobody over I thought
it's real quick
well you guys you guys don't drive so
fast right I saw you make the turn but I
didn't see I didn't expect to stop bro
that's why you don't follow so close
dummy
where's the safety
I thought I seen someone walking through
the front of the truck they do that all
the time to me you know I drive a lot
all right
let me go now
fall down
that's right getting lectured by a
roadie are we
how's that feel
no and I didn't see you
I'm looking in front of you
I feel bad
excuse me sir okay I mean interesting
how little he had to say
there it is uh that is but a New York
City Mobility Mary bicycle Harry I don't
know we'll figure something out from
bicycle Harry
[Applause]
H Street crew as bodybuilders This Is Us
in like what I don't know five months
the boys got a gym installed so now
um
okay hello
put my head in your thighs and squeeze
me like a watermelon what the [__]
my head Mommy
who is that yeah that's me yeah
I don't see it doesn't look anything
like me yeah not really something
happened there
this is Dan this is I like that Den what
do we think
I'm about to pop why is this dude got
these tiny little toy barbells
okay Dan
when myself
what the [__] who is Sam
awesome
uh awesome Ian oh my God Jesus I'm
feeling that Ian what are you feeling
I look like a rat
a [__] jacked rat
Lena
that's Lena in a couple months she's
training hard yeah yep soon enough
maybe that's basically already what you
look like
let's begin so thirst trapped that yours
is definitely the most Thunder strap
uh
everybody else is in the gym and it was
like a model here's my job
[Laughter]
Zach oh mama
talk to me baby
cam yeah that's one pointy chin what the
hell happened on that one
Olivia Olivia okay
no they didn't have to do that I don't
like that they did not have to love
you're awesome dude let's go dude that's
[__] holy [__] Juiced up dude he
got steroids
oh yeah you look good brother yeah
that's kind of a fun little uh
photo album thank you
that's how we're all gonna work soon
actually you guys do uh
weightlifting set for the office
thank you to OB returns for that
thank you so much
yeah there's also some drama at the LA
philharmonics
um over the weekend
now if you guys listen closely
apparently
maybe just play the audio first and then
apparently a woman had a full body
orgasm or just say it just from the
music
now is that just let's hear let's listen
[Music]
so do we have any more details on this
yeah I mean there's like a LA Times
article about it apparently it it did
really happen so she's orgasming well
but from the vibration
I think the music is just that good no
not from the vibration well how else do
you have an orgasm uh your boyfriend is
fingering you during oh okay so that
makes sense that makes sense I don't
know I disagree I disagree music can
make you bust enough yeah I mean
just been the music if you want to find
out Zach Lewis live with the Rocks you
may or may not bust the knife orgasm
guaranteed jizz flowing down your leg
like c-man
foreign
[Music]
how did they time that that's got to be
a gag
harmonic did an orgasm gag oh I think
someone in the eyes
that timing is crazy it's right at the
loaf
it's like a it's like a percussion
instrument it's definitely sounds
laughs
what are the what are the details of the
article say
uh just that it was reported by multiple
people and that uh what do you call it
the identity is unknown I guess people
couldn't figure out
who did it they didn't you can find the
person screaming at the top of their
life oh yeah in an auditorium of rows of
seats
everybody kind of turned to see what was
happening Grant who was seated near the
person who allegedly made the noise told
the times on Sunday in a phone interview
uh oh I saw the girl after it happened I
assume she dot dot dot had an orgasm
because she was heavily breathing and
her partner was smiling and looking at
her oh she probably had one of those
inserts like in an effort to not shame
her you've seen that [__] were they like
the boyfriend has the remote and she
puts like a thing up her ass or
something I don't know
multiple people who attended the concert
on Friday reported hearing the woman
making moaning noises during the second
movement
uh uh that's a movement there was a
movement all right
an alleged audio recording at the moment
where somebody can be heard crying out
during a quiet beat and the music was
mating in the rounds on social media
attendees who spoke to the time said the
clip was similar to what they'd heard so
I mean it's confirmed
I love her
[Applause]
people are still loving music as much as
they always have been Zach do you think
you could just buy just music I'll give
it a shot I don't know if Tchaikovsky
might I'll do it but um who's more
likely to make most of them make you
come your pants probably they got like a
Pink Floyd experience you know like true
black lights in your room just yeah the
lp like dark side during uh like great
gig in the sky I was about to say yeah
you got a great gig in my pants more
like yo let's go
hahaha
also before we get into the main story
here's a great
a great little story uh there's a big
incel Community okay and they have a
leader of the incel community who
apparently is like the Martin Luther
King Jr of incels
uh dude they really look up to this guy
and I'm telling you this man
he found somebody he he found the
significant other
and you would think that they would be
happy for him because that's the whole
point right I'm involved I'm
involuntarily celibate we want it but we
can't get it
no they feel betrayed yep check this out
they're having a meltdown
so this is the uh MLK Intel
I feel a lot of mixed feelings about
leaving the incel community I love that
this this man gets laid once and he's
like I'm leaving losers
well he's no longer celibate and by
definitionally he has to leave right
so you got to trade your membership card
just to have sex once because they're
they're like homies you know what I mean
but the whole I mean it involuntarily
celibate he's no longer involuntarily
celibate so he doesn't bust that right
yeah it's but you can have had sex and
still be an insult well once you've had
sex I feel like if you're in an Intel
Community don't you want to get away
from that Community as soon as possible
once you're not listen part of it if you
were sane you wouldn't ever want to be a
part of it to begin with right but
you're not a loser anymore well you'll
see that [__] yeah I'm out you know I
feel like I'd get away so quick it does
seem like it's a cause for celebration
yeah that's what I would think like he
did it he got out he made it out you
know like when someone makes it out of a
rough neighborhood he's he made it
[Music]
we all look up to him
uh he says I have a lot of mixed
feelings about leaving the incel
community while it feels good to no
longer be an Intel
I'm going to miss all the friends and
connections I've made to all of you who
have supported me over the years thank
you I start a new chapter in my life
albeit late so that it's really
fascinating he's like now that I've got
laid I will never be talking to any of
you ever again
yeah I mean forget you knew me
bye literally got [__] once
that's crazy man that's why we need sex
work because some of these dudes just
you know
I don't know am I right
let's read what let's read the thread
moving on
his homies in the response it's honestly
disgusting that you would betray your
community when some chick finally
settles for you
see these guys are so black pilled
any girl that would want to have sex
with any of them
is set like they can't take it because
she's settling so I have ice in my mouth
like there's no metrics where they can
win right
it's disgusting that you went and got
[__]
I love his response because it's just
like it really is amazing it's literally
the response that like everyone else in
the world would give to these guys
it is interesting to note that this he
had sex once and it's just immediate
like LOL okay
I'm not one of you no more
it is interesting to note that this
really pathetic incel
Avatar is a picture of Elon Musk
here's uh MLK and cell he says well
enjoy being a virgin for some weird
cause no one wants to be in so low we're
not Jedi
not no more bag
not anymore
now here's another one
he says why do you leave did you manage
to stop being an in cell and so then do
you feel no longer being identified with
so many sad depressed men out there it's
me imagine if normal people are clueless
and careless about being a virgin past
25 30 plus years old how is that how is
how is to have now careless X in cells
I'm sorry that was a hard read what is
going on with this guy
okay all right thank you for your input
there yeah he popped off
uh here's another one this is the
equivalent of LeBron retiring the incel
community has lost their biggest
Prospect what does that mean their
Prospect were you trying to [__] him
I don't know what he means by prospects
baffling
and so there's actually quite a bit more
a civil war is breaking out
yeah this is why the incel community
will never start a movement and bring
about what change
what are you fighting for
that you were forcing women to have sex
with you I don't understand you want to
legislate that well that's I guess if I
had to read into that a little bit it's
that it goes beyond
you know like the incel thing I think
started with like just a bunch of
depressed men that couldn't get laid you
know coping with each other but it it is
ideological now I think you know they
genuinely hate women and think that
they're all [__] and you know it's not
with me
they all want to uh they all see the
world like um Crowder you know what I
mean subservient woman kind of thing and
let me ask you this if they're all [__]
why is it that you can't get laid or
maybe I put it another way you're a
bunch of [__]
this is why the Intel Community will
never start a movement and bring about
change it only takes one hoe to
sacrifice herself and get some crumbs of
[__] and the whole movement would
collapse due to too many betraying yeah
what is your goal bro and also just like
that just you're right
and that shows how stilted and stupid
your entire movement is because it's all
just based on what no [__] does to a
[__] it's so delicate it can
literally die that quick that
rum exactly and your whole movement is
literally dead yeah
that's crazy but again this guy's like
it's now I'm in so deep it's now a
betrayal to have sex with a woman right
which is not
then you are then he's become
voluntarily celibate so it's no longer
an instant yeah it's full so yeah it's
full you're a full cell brother
uh MLK responds and seldom isn't some
club or movement it's a bunch of men who
are ostriches from society okay can't
experience preach
don't worry no one will miss you fake
cell oh again your opposer dude what are
we doing here you're [__] post here
bro
I hope the stinky hole you got was worth
it dude you're so listen to yourself
they hate women like what the [__]
that's crazy you you're upset that you
can't have sex
but then every woman's unfuckable and
what do you what's the and just you know
what I mean what's what's the end game
here I don't get it I think I think
we're making a mistake trying to reason
exactly the whole thing is just
nihilistic and stupid yeah uh he says I
get that but the less of us remaining in
the community the weaker our movement
and voice becomes yeah dude just yes
good I mean what move and then he says
there's no movement man this is MLK
speaking uh you know
in this allegory if you are staying a
virgin for some cause you need to stop
now and reflect deeply on life nowhere
in the right mind wants to be an Intel
look look out for you not abstractions
like movements okay this guy's kind of
preaching
like that's what I found sounds funny
about it because like I'm sure like a
week ago this guy was awful and probably
like you know just saying like the most
[__] up anti-women thing and then he
gets laid once and he's like bro come on
get over it it becomes like a PhD
in gender studies yeah
that's so interesting though
Traders someone called him to whom
he literally has a black icon so I think
you can see where he's coming from
this is where School shooters come from
I mean genuinely their world their world
view is so Bleak there's
There's No Escape
but you know the Intel movement I
understand from the start where it's
like you said Dad it's a bunch of dudes
who want to get laid who can't and it's
just a support Community because I get
it it's hard if you can't get laid if
you don't know how to interact with
women it's it's very you know it can
cause a lot of emotional um
psychological damage sure and so these
guys having a support group I totally
understand
right but it's you still want to get
laid Yeah and it's a mistake to to think
of it as a support group because really
it's the opposite they they all
I mean it's clear they all if anything
they're just tearing each other down
it's like the opposite of the support
group it's just like circles horrible
life is I hope that stinky hole is worth
it bro right yeah okay so ten [__] dudes
if you think it's a stinky hole then you
probably are either asexual or
homosexual
you know
they're like women are gross their
vaginas stink and they're gross and
they're stinky holes it's like okay
follow that keep following that
gay
[Laughter]
this man says stay in touch with your
friends at least he's the MLK says I
intend to but from the outside the
community is in cell only
he lost all credentials
don't you think he would be like an
incel idol he went through it he made it
so he should be able to bring that
knowledge back to them right if the yeah
yeah if the goal was to like get over
being an insole but I think this paints
a pretty clear picture that that isn't
actually the goal it's like a turn it's
it's a school shooter Factory yeah yeah
yeah
it's like um you know Jesus died and
then he came back
he's up
so in a sense it's like that it's the
it's the hero's Ark right he wins the
hero's journey right
the Beast you know got that post not
Clarity that's it right
he's so backed up man yeah 30 years of
nut hysteria yeah
that's tough man wow
she's oh will you let the lady know
you're a moderator for the world's most
prominent insult forum and congrats she
sees my Twitter she knows this man is
really laying the groundwork for a good
relationship
you know
good for him
he's honest
he's transcended this is MLK
we're gonna we're marching on Washington
it's a movement one taste of [__] pie
and a man will turn his back on his
friends like that
dude uh-huh what the [__]
[__] pie one taste of [__] pie and the
incel is no longer involuntarily
celibate yeah yeah that sounds about
right to me
that's how it works right yeah the
in-cell prophet he going to the top of
the mountain and bringing back the
tablets of
how to get laid for real
the ten [__] Commandments right he came
back with the Commandments and they were
you saw them all worshiping the air
worshiping Andrew Tate the golden idol
of Tate down there and he'd smashed the
tablets
the ten [__] Commandments Thou shalt
not
call it a stinkhole and [__] too
commandment two
Thou shalt shower regularly
everyone's like
[Music]
that oh wow
Commandments number three
of the [__] tablets
oh is this true I just saw somebody in
the chat say Hassan said that he's in
his 30s and she's 18. okay you know what
take what you can get bro
at least it's 18 the outcome is good I
think the outcome is good
good could be worse you know what oh
sure it certainly could I mean she could
be oh those 18. obviously
I lost my breath
but at the same time we gotta take we
gotta give the man a dub
you know
commandment number three
Thou shalt
have a job
[Laughter]
[Music]
commandment number four of the [__]
tablets
Thou shalt not call them [__] to their
face
commandment number five do not leave
loaded guns
on the wall and under your pillow
do not leave a kill list on the wall of
your door
do not leave the faces of all on your
kill list on a magnet on your
refrigerator
oh
yes commandment number five
don't worry about age no I'm kidding
I don't think they did anyway
really
I've seen people I guess 33 and 19 is
what I'm saying okay
[Music]
every year is a massive leap year every
every year is a big big step forward 19
okay 19. yeah you know I mean I mean
seriously it is happy it's 19. 19 is a
lot better than 18. it is the full 300.
somehow it is 19 and a half
that can make a big difference yeah okay
commandment number six
Thou shalt move out from your
grandmother's basement
what are we gonna do
yes
Commandments number seven
[Music]
of the [__] Commandments
Thou shalt get what you can get
lower thy standards
thou gets what he gets doesn't get upset
Commandments number eight of the [__]
Commandments
[Music]
uh do not
bring you uh
put anyone got any ideas no it's uh
harder than it seems isn't it Ten
Commandments it's a lot of Commandments
although in their original Commandments
that's why he's got
that's why he's Yahweh that's true
although again the for the original Ten
Commandments I still sometimes go back
because there's stuff like
I mean they've totally left out sex
crime
you know like that
I feel like that should have been a
commandment
isn't there like uh the covet yeah no
there's not you shall not commit
adultery no adultery is like infidelity
that's not a second but it's it was in
Hebrew translated to Greek translated to
English like no no adultery means it's
literally means voluntary sex between a
married person and a person who is not
okay their spouse
Thou shalt not have sexual course
against their will
it's the 10 [__] Commandments one you
know that biggest song One it doesn't
matter how long it takes if you get that
[__] then it's no mistake to
gotta set your standards low because
don't go for the top hoe sorry I'm just
doing rap stuff nope I don't like that
word
it's a bad word
anyway congratulations uh we went a
little bit down the meme hole one taste
of [__] pie and the man will turn his
back on his friends absolutely man
you [__] got that right and just
imagine how good that pie must taste my
friend
that's a good pie
so it's pretty interesting story it's a
it's a real fascinating Peak inside uh
the incel community
here
she knows right uh one taste of [__]
pie you'll be back bro he says no coming
back once you cross the bridge it's like
death
he crossed the bridge of life there's no
coming back
[__] watch it
you are the equivalent of a Dropout
having 600k in a [__] coin wallet get
rich quick get poor quick no one
confident will ever let himself be on
the verge of luck this man can't even
think outside Bitcoin analogies because
I don't even know what that means
you've already transcended bro you can't
even talk to them
yeah it's pretty weird man so there it
is
you know I was thinking I hate to bring
this back to you this is unrelated to
anything I was listening to Man in the
Mirror this morning and I do love that
song Michael Jackson
and I don't want to put you on the spot
but there's one point when people defend
him
is they say
he just didn't have a childhood he's
just a weird guy right it doesn't mean
that he's a is that is that did I
represent that right or is there a
different and I'm not I'm not trying to
put you on I'm just genuinely had a
thought
but you as the Michael MJ uh
I don't say your Defender I won't put
that on you but you're
sympathy adjacent I don't know nothing
about anything but yeah some people yeah
some people say that I've heard that
okay because then because my thought I
was always like yeah pedophiles were
never weird guys
you're right he's just weird pedophiles
are always super
super normal
I'm sorry but dude the dude's a
pedophile
he's weird
he's just weird he didn't have a
childhood
yeah pedophiles are [__] up in the
head that's how they become pedophiles
[Music]
you know his music's great though don't
get me wrong
good music I can fire
musical Genius of course
I'm gonna ask Chachi BT to defend
Michael Jackson
I'm curious because I understand that
you don't want to get involved baby it's
dicey
doesn't care
damn it why is it not logged in
why why like this why like this
why like this all right I'm out I'm
logged somebody logged me out on purpose
I see how it is
can I do a poll I just want to know how
many of y'all think MJ did it
like genuinely I'm curious
there's a lot of people that still
defend him
they say zero evidence
oh yeah no it's crazy it's super hard to
believe that MJ's a [__] pedo
foreign
ass man sleeps in the bed with kids by
his own admission
and you're telling me
he didn't flick their dick one time
being in that bed with them just think
about it use your brain who can do it on
a pole here
fans are gone
think love can love can you do a poll
um I'm gonna have to log in
like those to do I don't have the button
on mine
well could you sit and dance chair and
do it
you know MJ did he do it yes or no
you know he did that [__] and don't get
me wrong I love that motherfucker's
music boy I'll tell you what man I'm
looking at the man in the mirror and he
did not change his ways he kept [__]
kids
um
oh Chachi Boutique uh they said
let's see here
not guilty Michael Jackson was acquitted
in 2015.
inconsistency and accuse their stories
some sport is Michael Jackson have
pointed out consistencies
Financial motive some Defenders argue
the accusers were motivated by money
character Witnesses numerous individuals
who knew Michael Jackson well including
family members friends say he would
never do that that's compelling yeah
I'm sorry guys this is not that good
media portrayal
he was uh bot people were biased
humanitarian work yeah of course yeah no
no humanitarian work and philanthropy I
mean that would never never
did MJ do it oh yeah 82 these are my
people
just use your [__] brain I'm sorry
if you had an uncle that was like yeah
you know I I like to have the
neighborhood kids over my house when we
sleep in our bed together
that's it that's all you know about him
because with Michael we know a lot more
but let's just say that yeah my Uncle
Jim he has the neighborhood kids over
only boys only boys are loud in his bed
by the way cute boys like Model boys
I didn't know he ever admitted to that
Baby Gap
yes he did he said we slept in beds it's
innocent
he admitted to it he said I used to
share my bed with uh because we're just
having a sleepover because he's just
like a kid
I'm just a kid that's news to me I never
knew he said that okay so that's okay so
it's in a tree here that's an interview
of him sitting in a tree talking about a
bunch of weird [__] well hold on let me
pull up the receipts because if I have a
opportunity to sway a B I think that's
special I didn't I'm not saying anything
listen no I know I know my idea of
listen where I grew up predominantly my
my friends around me and close family
friends were all African-American and
their explanation of things may have
influenced me they and this was prior to
any of the recent stuff that came up so
I grew up thinking about I think Michael
Jackson a little bit differently because
of that because of my friends and family
friends uh when I came here I made a
comment about the documentary and I
think because of that that led to
some other stuff saying more than uh
some people think I'm saying more than I
am but well I do when I when that
leaving Neverland documentary came out I
went through [__] war with the
Michael Jackson stands you remember that
damn that was ugly for a while
I remember
but I wasn't backing down from that one
because I was sure I was right but
people got real angry but it's nice to
see 81 say yes Michael Jackson did that
[__] and I mean listen
your uncle
I'm let me let me just say something and
I'm not saying because he's black that's
why he was defendants because it's no
secret that a lot of these black artists
were treated like [__] and they went
through [__] throughout their whole
careers I'm not saying because they're
black they were defending him that's
y'all saying that I didn't say that
um
here's a good here's a good comment uh
from Brooklyn xox the weekly Ethan tries
to cancel a b no that's not true why are
we talking but it's not about that at
all ABY
was there some Michael Jackson like news
or something no I just had a thought
this morning totally unrelated I was
listening
a man in the mirror came on my radio
and um
I just started thinking because the one
thing that always was like he's just
weird he's just a weird guy he just he
doesn't have a childhood he just likes
hanging out with kids and I'm like name
one [__] other person
or that
you know oh I just my uncle just likes
hanging out with kids
oh [__] we gotta we got a [__] video
clip
bro you wake up at night and that face
is one inch from you
what do you do
come on
come on man
[Music]
sorry I'm trying to go back
I don't know why we can't on shorts but
is it really appropriate for a 44 year
old man to share a bedroom
with a child who is not related to him
at all that's a beautiful thing it's a
beautiful thing that's not a worrying
thing I should be wearing who's the
criminal who's Jack the Ripper in the
room
again your uncle says this at
Thanksgiving dinner
you like these [__] kids
Uncle Jeff
he [__] kids
there's a guy trying to help heal a
child oh yeah I'm sleeping in a sleeping
bag on the floor I gave him the bed
cause he has a brother named star so him
and star took the bed and I'm on the
floor in the sleeping bag did you ever
sleep in the bed with them no liar but I
have to open a bed with miniature okay
there it is baby
I have slept in the bed with many
children many this way has got like a
kid Factory running through there bro
damn
if that bed could talk
um
that's what I'm saying
[Music]
would sleep on this side my color cup is
on this side his sister's in there we're
all just jamming the bed and we wake up
wake up go in the hot air balloon
[Music]
it's very right it's very right it feels
great it feels right it just feels right
but my point is it's like yeah
pedophiles are never weird they go he's
just a weird guy right
pedophiles are usually super normal
um this music is uh copyright [__] did
we get notified no I just see people
saying that it is in the chat is that
overlaid or is that from the document
Alana song They're saying okay we'll
deal with it really appropriate okay
well whatever so there it is
so will you right now uh will you now
um
what's the word
will you now denounce Michael Jackson a
b
will you at this moment right now say I
denounced Michael Jackson and all that
happened in his bed the many children
that came and went like a goddamn
Chuck E cheese they come and they go
it's like a ball pit up in that [__]
many kids have slept in my bed
you watch it will you now denounce
Michael Jackson
I don't know nothing about anything
but we just watched the interview of him
saying he slept in bed with a lot of
kids a lot of them
and then after this interview Michael
released his footage showing how this
footage was manipulated
oh he's so Michael says that that was
taken out of context I don't know about
this specific clip but this whole Martin
beshear interview he released his
footage of the incident after because of
the way stuff was portrayed in the
documentary
um
okay there it is
kids loved Hitler
Let's Love Hitler all right let's move
it on there you go see
he's innocent
we all know it
moving on
all right let's talk about Adam Ross
shall we
[Laughter]
uh
hey everybody
Aiden Ross
is a giant piece of [__]
in fact he's caused a war a rift
with Hassan [__]
w
there was once a chance for Aiden Ross I
feel like and Hassan was even reaching
out to him
you know
here it is Aiden Ross first files a
false copyright claim on YouTuber
internet and Anarchist video also he
says that he's Hassan's head mod which
is weird apparently Hassan doesn't even
know who the guy at all
uh here he is
on stream doing it
Aiden Ross celebrating his false
copyright claims on my content
foreign
he tweeted out I just lost 8 000 from
Aiden Ross false claiming my video about
the penguin versus Nico situation
penguin wait
see that seems like super I haven't seen
the video in question but dude you're
not going to lose the money just dispute
it dispute it it goes into an escrow
account
you'll get it back you know what I mean
um
has anybody watched this video in
question
I'm assuming it's like a video essay so
it's super fair use this is um Hassan's
head moderator chat put him up in the
chat we stole eight thousand dollars
from them W
he needed that yeah
W yes oh yes dude what a scumbag
first of all it's not Hassan's head
moderator they don't have any
association and even if it was this man
like why are you celebrating stealing
money from a hard-working American
after we all thought
um I'm not sure because he has a few
videos on it
um and I'm not sure because this one
appears to be like a further update so
this might not be the actual one but you
can immediately tell I mean this is like
highly edited like commentary video
um
this is 100 original content yeah I mean
it seems like this is the type of
content they do so it's his video
um sneako's horrible response to penguin
zero so not new response to penguin zero
oh no it's that one from a month ago to
the right
down
oh this one yeah click that after being
completely and utterly humiliated by
Charlie snake I would come out with one
of the worst results
okay so yeah I mean this is 100 original
Aiden Ross is a [__] little [__] for
that so it just like has Kelly sneak it
was horrible video wait this isn't Sunny
V2
that is the same [__] voice I'm
adamant on that
Gaya
play it let me hear turned him gay
stating so he he really doesn't like the
fact that I supported the movie cuties
but cuties is actually a movie about
Islamic faith it's about how Western
degeneracy can corrupt people and why
Tick-Tock is bad for you nobody who
hates that movie actually saw it it's
about a western African family that
looking like he sleeps under a bridge or
me who looks like a pedophile really
weird [__] like all right whatever
whatever I've listened to everyone so
this video now puppy it was
copyright law is really [__] up
because
it gives almost no protection against
copyright trolls and so here's Aiden on
camera saying the trick is and I've been
looking
for a good situation for me to sue
someone doing a fake copyright because I
want to strengthen the laws defending uh
creators to make people pause before
just throwing a claim on a video
and the problem is is that the language
in the law
it says
you have to
you only have to believe that you're
right you don't have to be right you
only have to believe you're right
the only way to actually sue someone is
if you have a video or an email or
something of them saying I know this is
wrong and I'm doing it anyway
so the bar is super [__] hard to hit
and I've been waiting I've been looking
and I swear I'm looking and waiting for
the perfect opportunity to sue someone
now when we're watching this video to
see if this guy internet Anarchist has a
case
there needs to be evidence that what
Aiden's doing he knows is the wrong
thing and he's doing it maliciously
W chat by the way this is um Hassan's
head moderator chat put him up in the
chat we stole eight thousand dollars
from him W now the word stole might be
operating doing some lifting there as it
implies that he wrongfully
took it so that so that's something he
needed that yeah
I know there's obviously malice involved
as he's celebrating it yes
W yes yes oh yes so I think I'd I'd like
to see more of what he said to know
but like on this face value I think it's
an okay case it's pretty good it's
better than most that I've seen in terms
of pursuing legal action
um
it's undoubtedly scummy as [__] all
of hell I mean what is wrong with you
bro this man gets paid millions of
dollars a month
for this kick [__] and he's
celebrating ceiling 8000 what happened
to him
he wasn't like full-blown evil vile like
a year ago
but uh this is very interesting he says
he claims I am Hassan's head moderator I
have no idea where he got that from
um
YouTube already confirmed that the
claiming partner would be penalized oh
really
that's interesting
or did they say that
heard back we found out that this claim
is invalid and I've already taken
appropriate action on the relevant
reference okay
so it sounds like YouTube made the call
that it was fair use in terms of him
being celebrated again or a punished I
don't I don't see it happening because
again
his footage was in it
it's really [__] up but now let's go
on to Hassan because this is where all
this drama started and then Hassan quote
tweeted uh Aiden Ross
ah
he said uh this dude isn't my head mod I
don't know them you false striked me as
well for a video I was in and here you
are dumb enough to celebrate false
copyright striking people
Aiden Ross hitting new levels of
stupidity I never knew were reachable
okay
so
then Hassan reacted on stream
he says he re-uploaded this clip to his
official Channel
with the description I'm not a litigious
person I prefer to resolve things
quickly but at this time I'll sue so
Hassan is threatening to sue
little Aiden Ross
the little sniff Cedar
sniff Cedar seats
yes
uh he says he also received a false
copyright strike from Aiden Ross on his
video debating Andrew tape since it was
Aiden's stream so this is where it gets
kind of interesting
uh here's a
so what happened was Hassan
took a clip of his debate
with Andrew Tate
and put it on his channel now he was in
the clip
right
but the clip was taken from Aiden Ross's
Channel
let's take a look
why I mean he was recording when that
happened he was not recording I asked
him asked him oh okay the only only xqc
and Aiden Ross have scream recordings of
it and he used Aiden Ross's as you can
tell from the Social Links in the bottom
but here's his son talking about it
let's see identical for the record he
just uploaded a video which is Juicy
Juicy hot Goss do not f with me Adam
Ross
he's pissed
my man's mad a copyright claim was
created for Content Andrew take cannot
handle my questions thumb media claimed
it on behalf of Aiden this is the video
I'm right here the entire content of
this video is me debating Andrew Tate if
anything I should be able to [__]
content claim Aiden Ross for trying to
[__] pose this as his own content as
all he did was sit there like a [__]
dumbass I'm literally in the middle of
the [__] video are you out of your
[__] mind dude and his dumb ass
[__] fan base turned around this has
1.5 million views on my YouTube channel
and they're just trying to [__] milk
it they're trying to take these views
and trying to make money off of the
video that absolutely is is uh a video
that I could claim is mine it's crazy
I'm on the video like that is the next
level of of so uh copyright [__] I
see that the video is
the the video from the runtime it
doesn't appear to be the full debate or
or it's probably like an edited version
of it right
uh it would be yeah it would like it
wasn't just the entire you see the
runtime of it where did you see the
runtime you had it up a second ago
wherever that was
I'm also seeing people in the chat the
same
so okay so that actually that could be a
compelling argument for fair use because
if they cut it up to focus on Hassan's
involvement right
but at the end of the day and listen
what Aiden Ross did is [__] crazy
he's breaking all Norms all professional
norms
you know he's Burning Bridges
and there's an unspoken rule of creators
especially on Twitch I mean my God you
invite someone on
to juice your [__] Channel and then
you copyright claim them I mean it's
psychotic yes but
here's the video the video is uh 19
minutes long
and and is it edited or how does it cut
through
uh you would have to be because that
whole thing was way longer than that
right was it I don't know because he he
didn't talk for Tate for very long
because Tate hung up with him he made
him hang up because he's a little [__]
he's like does anyone really want to
talk to him yeah I don't think it's
edited I think it's the whole interview
well they add some context and stuff but
it's not substantially transforming it
yeah I mean I would have to watch
a bunch of it to see if it's cut but
here's my take
and I
I hate to say it because Hassan is right
he's right
the problem is is the copyright law
gives no protection to people like
Hassan
but in terms of who owns that recording
I mean technically it would be Aiden
Ross who owns it
it was filmed on his channel
it has his watermarks on it I asked
Hassan I was like damn you know
apparently Hassan didn't film it
and so he was using Aiden Ross's clip
recording of it now if Hassan filmed the
same exact footage but he filmed it it
would be his
footage
xqc recorded his then that one's his
footage that he owns theoretically right
or at least there's a
there's a good faith enough assumption
to where you can't accuse them of you
know of abusing the system
and so
I told his son cut it up from excuses
and re-upload it and then if he takes it
down
then what he's doing is illegal because
he has no he has no claim oh next right
but
um
unfortunately I don't believe
that there's anything we can do about it
I really don't
you know as [__] up as it is yeah
and as shitty as a person he is and what
a douche man I mean you know that's the
thing Hassan is right he is right
I'm just playing it back in two speed
just to see and I have been seeing it
jump cut a little bit so there
definitely was like jumps around and the
added stuff but like you said I I don't
know I mean if it's enough to make the
argument that is my opinion it's
probably not just being real
you know I think if a judge reviewed
that they'd probably say that
it's not different enough right
that it becomes its own
separate property
foreign
if you want to sue him do this because
xqc's recording's still up
re-upload from xqc xqc is not going to
take yours down
wait for him to take it down and then we
got something interesting you know if
Hassan owned it and he did that then
we'd be talking right if it was his
footage right but Aiden Ross uh is very
[__] dumb and somehow luckily
got this right
unfortunately
from a legal standpoint from a legal is
not a moral standpoint yeah he just by
dumb luck
uh is on the legal right side of this w
what that was my problem that was my
issue I guess I never signed a [__]
release suck my [__] I'll see you in
court you stupid [__] you [__]
imbecile you absolute [__] dumbass
holy [__] you stupid little I mean I'm
right there with him I'm right there
with him there's nothing worse than you
know and we have this understanding
amongst us that you just don't do that
thing it's a can of worms
yeah and especially in this circumstance
where it's like a collaborative call you
guys were all making the contests
Together made that Viral moment right
right
there wouldn't have been anything
without that incident nothing yeah
that's a good point yes so you know some
thanks
but
yeah sucks idiotic baboon-like thing to
[__] do you still going
you signed a release what release did I
sign you stupid [__] did you yeah
unfortunately and
again
Hassan is right
he is right
but I don't think a release form has
anything to do with the fact that he
owns
that clip
you know
pay me to appear on that [__] but I
think Hassan could also make a good
faith argument about the I think it's
fair use you know there's room to argue
it I think it's fair use so I just hope
and I think he did I told his son just
just dispute it
you know we have a fair use belief we
have a we have a it's arguable if it
could be fair use right you know it's
not for us Society it's for a judge to
decide
and uh then you'll you'll get the money
back you won't [__] do [__] he's not
gonna do [__] well and also
how does it work when it's like because
this was like a year ago
um and I have to imagine you know that
video had what do we say 1.5 million
views or whatever I mean almost all of
those had to have been oh you don't get
money retrospectively
if that's what you're gonna ask
retroactively yeah yeah no right so him
claiming it now it's not like gonna like
you said retroactive no deduct that
money from no it's just from that point
right it goes into an escrow account
because Hassan disputed it right so once
the dispute is resolved between them
which Hassan is going to win then all
the money that was earned during that
escrow period will go to back to Hassan
right it doesn't which would probably be
minimal just because this is such an old
clip nobody's really watching that
anyway yeah okay now the other guy who I
guess he claimed his video from the
beginning
then you know that hurts eight thousand
dollars for a small Creator I mean
that's [__] insane that's really bad
yeah that guy by the way has 200 000
Subs on YouTube which makes Aiden's
confusion about him being Hassan's mod
even funnier well his whole channel are
like pretty well produced yeah uh video
essays
now granted I don't know much about that
I don't know anything about that creator
the historian or the YouTube Anarchist
but based on what little we saw you know
now I'm seeing some people I don't know
anything about this maybe you've heard
of this I guess why that little part
where he's talking about the release
I'm seeing chatter say
that the argument is that
if you're in the video and you didn't
sign a release it's obtainable the video
is rights are obtainable by all parties
involved I think that's why he was
talking about the release thing I don't
I don't
think that that's necessarily how I
don't think that's how it works I don't
know
because when you create when you
it doesn't maybe it gets it yeah I mean
that's I don't know maybe I don't think
that's how it works but maybe again so
so maybe yeah but there's enough room
right
to
but again you can't sue it in Ross
unless you can prove that he did that
knowing it was wrong and I don't think
you can do that
because it is his footage at the end of
the day right yeah it would be hard to
prove that
I wish we could sue him I'd love to sue
him
like I said I've been looking for an
opportunity to do this
praying waiting
I says come at me people please
you know
and I want to say this I have never
claimed another video in my whole life
I've removed a couple who there were uh
wholesale re-uploads of our podcasts
especially when we were on Twitch and
people would screen record it and upload
it before we even posted to YouTube
which would like [__] up the algorithm
but I have never claimed a video
I don't believe in it
Zoom call oh no you didn't suck my dick
you don't own that [__] content it's
quite literally me in the [__] video
see you in court like you're gonna do
[__] what do you mean you think I you
think I'm not gonna pursue this you
think I'm not gonna [__] counter are
you stupid this is such an objectively
incorrect thing to do and this [__]
dumbass is also again stupid enough to
like do this not only is he stupid
enough to do this he's done it to so
many people and most importantly perhaps
most significant someone said there's a
contract attorney in chat who
contract attorney
someone said there was literally a
contract attorney lawyer in chat today
oh you're talking about Hassan's Chef oh
and Hassan's chat sounds like Hassan's
right yeah I'm sure
I'm yeah I'm doing a little bit of
reading about it and I see where let's
ask Chachi Beach that's what I did yeah
yeah and it's a little ambiguous but it
you know it's answer well here's the
thing that if you appear in a video
without giving permission
uh you may have certain rights related
to privacy and likeness it's important
to note that copyright rights uh
copyright and rights to privacy and
likeness are separate legal Concepts
that's why you do so that's my
understanding is that the release is
about privacy right and it's about
likeness not necessarily about ownership
the ownership so like on the internet
um when you publish something you
immediately get the copyright for it
and so
generally type what are released forms
used on you know I mean what's the
purpose of them
because
it's Mo I think it's so that you can't
get an attorney and be like yo you owe
me money for using my likeness and stuff
like that
right I mean that makes sense and yeah
it does seem like that's kind of like a
a separate issue at hand Christian says
that I have thyroid cancer she says you
think you should get a full thyroid
panel sounds like Hashimoto's
holding weight skin rash gerd all
symptoms
[__] is Hashimoto's
I have to have a checkup soon I'm going
to do a full blood panel
is an autoimmune disorder can cause
hypothyroidism
rarely disease can cause okay I mean
sure I'll do that
worth checking out
if the symptoms line up
how is the rash did it go away it's yeah
it's gone okay well that's good well I
showed the dermatologist and they didn't
think it was like a problem they just
didn't tell me why it happens
it says it's kind of like this is kind
of like a
an allergy but not really here so
symptoms constipation difficulty
concentrating or thinking
hmm dry skin enlarged neck
or presence of a goiter fatigue I am
fatigued hair loss hair loss okay maybe
not
heavy or irregular periods hmm
let me think about it this intolerance
to cold that's fascinating you are you
complain constantly about it being cold
in here
and Hot and Hot that's true I'm very
temperamental mild weight gain
not mild I ain't got no mild weight gain
well you're losing weight so
small or shrunken thyroid gland well
anyway I'll do the I'm I'm have a
general checkup I'm gonna do when is
that Lena my general checkup
are you she on the phone
I don't think she heard you she might be
on the phone or something
I think it's next week I'm gonna say do
all the [__] blood tests all the
fingers you know what I mean I want
oh you got to save it save yourself for
the show
I would never cheat on you guys like
that my butthole is yours my friends
it's very kind of you
you know
by the way the poll is still being voted
on 82 percent says yes Michael did it uh
Dante donated ten dollars and says you
don't have Hashimoto what do I believe
you've been cleared I don't know what to
vote well they donated ten dollars how
much did the other person donate
I think it was only five
you know I don't have it all right never
mind I'm not doing the test thank you
Dante I'm not a doctor
hahaha
um so did you did you chat gbt what is a
release form used for
I sent it in Discord oh thank you I mean
yeah it's like you said it's for your
likeness where these forms are used to
legally protect individuals or argon
organizations from potential legal
claims or liabilities these forms are
typically used to obtain permission to
use someone's image likeness Voice or
other personal or intellectual
properties for specific purposes so what
it says when you sign a release is
you're agreeing not to sue them for
having you in the in their video in the
video it doesn't mean that you can use
the footage
yeah I mean that wouldn't yeah because
then you know it kind of doesn't make
sense yeah yeah
let's go
I mean you can have an appearance
agreement that says that but that's a
separate thing right
so as much as I
I want significantly he's dumb enough to
gloat that he's false copy striking
people you [__] idiots look at him
W what are you doing this is um
where's that where's my Andrew Tate
underwear I want to sniff it
sounds like every boy in middle school
all right there chat put it up in the
chat we stole eight thousand dollars
from him W
he needed that the stole word is
that's not good is is definitely
interesting
but that one's about the other guy it's
not about right that's that one's not
about I think that guy has a has a
potential
a potential case and those those videos
were so cut and dry yeah not even
debatable yeah
I mean he's [__] a scumbag though and
that's what I'm saying I mean Hassan is
right
what is this one it's Hustler University
what is this one
just showing some of the edits that were
added to Hassan's VOD or his video
like this was in the original video that
Hassan uploaded yeah so he was even
giving clout
to them is that the point yeah just to
show that he was transforming it in some
way yeah he was giving context to
specific points he was making by like
showing oh yeah we saw yeah
yeah you sent that a while ago you just
see it till now Dante says okay I'm as
much as a doctor as Dr Dre so Dante says
Dr Dre's a real doctor
Dre or Dr Drew Dr Dre Doctor Drew
doctor both
so I don't know if there's more to this
but Aidan Ross is for sure giant piece
of [__]
uh Dre received an honorary degree in
1995 from the University of Southern
California and the subject of rap and
hip-hop so uh he is a doctor yo he is
from the USC that's fat that's a fat
credentials
he donated a whole [__] building
there too so oh that's what PhD
mm-hmm
I'm gonna get myself a PhD someday then
you'll have to call me doctor
Dr Klein
so uh I don't know
what do we do what do we do about it
what are we gonna do about it
because well Aiden's banned on Twitch is
he still on YouTube
I think he's exclusive he's exclusive to
kick is he not he probably uploads like
some content yeah so he doesn't give a
[__] about anything oh no he's still up
okay listen to this
this dude doesn't get [__] oh well he
gets some this is two days ago 59 000
views w
ow he's going crazy opening CS go cases
dude the only time he gets views is when
he talks about Andrew Tate so I guess
that explains why he's always on his
death so [__] hard Andrew taping
poisoned actually you know what that was
the dumbest story
that Andrew erased because it was so
dumb we talked about on Friday let's see
what how Aiden reacts to this I'm
curious what this dick rider says it's
just something bad I just don't
understand it bro like why can't
everyone just off and let people live
and just okay literally no response to
murder why can't people just [__] off
and let everybody live He's explicitly
not doing that he's [__] stealing
money by his own word stealing money
from smaller creators out of spite
what the [__] are you talking about dude
you're not doing it
come on bro he's ruining his life like
he's never I feel like when the Adam
Ross hype is gone
is it not
well I I think he actually pulls pretty
good numbers on kicks still
I guess he's although I'll say he'll be
Rich Forever from the amount of money
he's getting yeah he's fine
unless the government take I mean unless
the agency investigates which is I guess
possible
it's not exactly Fair gotten cash
this video
I didn't even see This I Swear
this tweet saying if
and he said hard to breathe some sort of
severe reaction or poison
face swollen blood pressures
um
you might have a thyroid problem
yo you have Hashimoto's
you need to do a thyroid panel quick let
me see real quick
trying to think face swollen blood
pressure through the roof skin don't buy
a heart of breathe some sort of severe
reaction to poison only a call from
coffee and water so far today what do
you guys think Chad do you guys think
that
do you guys think that they're trying to
[__] with injury the coffee rules so far
today all the people if someone in this
world were really being poisoned and
killed and you know what do you think
chat
do you think he's gonna make it we think
like that's a crazy
one in chat if you want him to live yeah
give us a dove if you want Andrew Tate
to live Chad is Right China's right
only had coffee and water
yes
took over his Twitter and said Andrew's
not allergic to anything this has never
happened before that's scary bro pouring
coffee today that's scary oh you got
some Matrix attack Insanity in his
bottled water he's refusing this video
has a million views he has not said
almost he said like three words that's
crazy
sucks
that is crazy Dan well said that's crazy
I was emulating his commentary
and breathe in we'll keep you all about
two's in the chat I'm noticing
guys two's in chat if you want him to
die
or well yeah to die from poisoning which
we had nothing to do with
I don't know anything about poison I
don't live in Romania I don't know
nothing about Romania
twos in chat
one inch shot if you want them to live
twos and chats if you want them to die
guys let's get those votes up
one prayer equals one second more life
that's how that works
let's get those prayers in chat guys
come on let's get them rolling in here
for Tate
oh [__] I'm seeing lots of twos [__]
yeah you guys are Savage not even a
single one for Tate
oh no
oh even a Nook is a guy is oh look
just the two two I'm seeing fours which
I think is two twos eight
yeah I don't see it I have literally not
seen a single one hmm
damn
poor guy he's definitely gonna die so
the pain is part of life he says doctors
and kill him
I love that like these guys like rushed
out to make content about this and they
had like this whole video he deleted
those tweets like three hours later
because I'm sure the rash went away yeah
and he's realized he looks like a little
[__] like imagine I get these weird
rashes all the time I'm like guys I
think I'm dying somebody poisoned me
you should do that next time it happens
yeah he's so cool he's so badass next
time you have a break out of that rash
it's a little itchy you guys what do I
do I'm being poisoned
I don't know see a dermatologist bro
you know what I mean do what I did just
some ointment
not that serious the question is where's
this come from why is he talking like
that though bro why is the narrator
speaking like that it's an accent Aiden
laughs
[Laughter]
oh Lord
I mean that's pretty much the answer
that's it
[Music]
bro come on bro this is serious as [__]
bro
god dude what the [__] he is so
he was such a good little Jewish boy
he was I don't know what happened
you know
that's what I wonder too all the Jewish
grandmas at home are just nodding their
head man yeah
still two's in chat [__] you know
this is super super scary oh my god look
how scary that looks oh my God like it's
pretty cool
oh my god look how scary that looks
that's what the narrator said it's like
I can't even tell if it's red frankly no
that was me after Ren Fair straight up
right like just a little bit of Tucson
that's what my shoulders got
yeah my face is sunburned right now do
you think I care being poisoned cam I
just saw you what do you think Chad is
he about to die yeah I hope huh look at
it there's a little red on his nose I
have a constant red face I'm always I'm
always literally poisoned
I was born with this [__] I'm scared
it's cursed you guys I can't play it
it's cursed I'm not talking about his ax
I'm talking about the way he's ending
his sentences am I hating dumbass I'm
just scared this is scary as [__] all
right I'm seeing Andrew Tate literally
poisoned and then I see my best friend
[__] like bro just tell her shit's
happening bro what damn I'm sorry I'm
just freaking out bro all your boyfriend
listen 023 Felix and he called his best
friend it's so embarrassing man
he's your best friend that grown ass man
I mean that's pretty much the same as
Michael Jackson calling a little kid his
best friend
he's my best friend
he's my best friend we sleep in the bed
together
seeing Andrew Tate literally poisoned
and then I see my best friend [__]
like bro just tell her shit's happening
bro I don't think it's fair that
whenever I want to talk about Michael
Jackson it's got to be a diss on a B I
was talking about Michael Jackson always
he's always been the best towards me
that's the problem well there's nobody
else in here that's going on I've never
been publicly defending when we brought
this up it was about the documentary
that was it and then I learned quickly
not to talk about that and so I didn't
well it that was when I first started I
was fresh out of Detroit too let me just
let me say so what's the problem you get
[__] from people for from defend or not
no I understand I spoke with people I
understand why you shouldn't even the
documentary alone why you shouldn't
speculate on stuff like that so I I just
don't want to because they're right you
shouldn't so that's why I don't
okay
cool
also sorry Ethan I was on the phone when
you asked but your checkup is next week
okay good
write down write down uh Hiroshima
disease
is it Hiroshima no it was not
Hashimoto's yeah yeah that sounds right
interestingly people in Hiroshima May
develop Hashimoto's
potentially from the uh
radiation I don't know
okay I mean I'm not you know what I mean
I'm just
uh you know
okay
the building constructive but just a
white potato communities would turn it
across that just mean that's what I
think
yeah
okay when I when I bring up Michael
Jackson I will no longer invoke the name
of a b who is pleading the fifth has
absolved his hands of any Michael
Jackson involvement
right
right it's also just a dead like I still
don't understand what we're even talking
about I think it's stuff I like it I
mean I still like talking about Michael
Jackson to this day
you know the little little old hat at
this point I just five years ago the
documentary came out five years okay
well what do you want me to stop talking
about Hitler yeah it was you know
80 years ago come on things happen
you know I heard his music this morning
on the radio that's why I talked about
the Med's still in my life right okay
you heard Hitler's music on the radio
yeah it was a sick remix bro no I didn't
it was a uh David Guetta German remix
all right I'm sorry baby I didn't mean
to uh I don't want to uh yesterday was
Hitler's death don't do any [__] by the
way I was Hitler shout out shout out to
all those who celebrate wait his per I
thought it was 4 20. his death day his
death oh his death day yeah yeah so do
people celebrate his death day
like do his supporters like do it up but
uh I doubt it
doesn't seem like something to celebrate
I threw a party yesterday I don't know
what you're talking about I like to have
a themed party where I'm in a bunker
it's on fire
this one do you know that Twitter
account it's uh World War II in real
time
I've heard of it I haven't been really
excited to it they've been doing it for
like I think over a decade at this point
and they just Tweet stuff that happened
that day in order in sequential order
over the years or whatever well they
finally reached 1945 so yesterday they
were live tweeting Hitler committing
suicide it's exciting it was a big day
and what's the day and so if they get to
keep talking about that I get to keep
talking about Michael Jackson
right thank you
I mean
Ethan Michael Jackson Tick-Tock in real
time
right if you start a social media
account dedicated to uh documenting his
life in real time wait is David Gupta
not German I swear I just like saw
something somebody say that recently
I thought he was I don't know David oh
he's French okay my bad
don't put that on him I I that's my bad
that's my bad by the way uh since it
just randomly came up
about once a day I get somebody who
sends me the video of him at uh recently
I think it was Ultra Music Festival uh
supposedly doing another uh shout out to
the family moment where he dropped a
song for gay rights
um it's fake that video is fake uh I
just want to announce that now so you
all can stop sending it to me it is a
funny video it's a great edit but it is
not real that is why we didn't cover it
on the show I think it was a Macklemore
remix too
what's it really yeah it's tied into two
topics
um Bella Simmons thank you for the
gifted by the way
did I miss any big ones love
uh there's been quite a few if you want
me to I have the spreadsheet open if you
want me to
recap some of the big ones yeah let's
thank some folks let's see here here
I'll mute this you guys can as we read
it off you can you can watch
as uh
Andrew Tate
skin deteriorates off his body like a
flesh eating bacteria or something
freaking out bro okay
uh let's see here uh there was a 50 one
uh from Shams saying just want to say I
appreciate Ethan Elon the entire game
crew thank you for getting me the rough
times
uh
there's another one uh twenty dollar one
from KP I don't think we read this Ethan
your rash is starting to sound like Red
Skin Syndrome slash red scope scrotum
syndrome okay okay hold on hold on red
scrotum syndrome
are they trolling or is that real thing
I really bro there's no way that's real
they are Loosely understood conditions
associated with the use of topical
steroids I don't use the steroid cream
in the past that's grow jump syndrome I
don't use it that much let me see red
scrotum syndrome is it real thing y'all
it's called RSS damn red scrotum
syndrome is a rare disease characterized
by persistent redness of the scrotum and
may involve the P the base of the penis
as well
accompanied by itching burning and pain
how do we get that
red scrotum it sounds like from a
steroid or something according to this
uh donation maybe my maybe I've read
scrotum disease thank you for that I'll
make sure to bring that up to the doctor
as well it was a wild I'm about to like
uh I'm gonna go to the doctor and like
unfurl a giant scroll you know what I
mean
here's all my conditions so I I live
stream a show and uh I've been taking a
lot of medical advice from my
Channel's red scrotum disease
I love that that's real man that's
fantastic
uh I see a bunch from back when we were
watching the uh mega church thing James
River who is the that's the church that
did the tank thing uh also never call me
back what the [__] Howards
what it what is this set
James River also claimed they grew a
woman's toe vac last month after praying
over it it's all over Google
grew back yo generated pull that up
right now I'm converting if that's real
[__] I'm going I love that
the best Miracle you can perform is just
someone's toe one toe growing back
that's all God's willingness to regrow a
miracle pastor says with no proof oh he
didn't have proof let's chuck oh yeah
Missouri Pastor that prayer regrew a
woman's amputated toes a website is
asking for proof without showing photo
or video evidence James River Church
Pastor John Lindell that was the host of
the the men's event or whatever uh told
his congregation a creative Miracle took
place involving a woman uh
yeah video from the conference has been
removed from the church's Facebook page
wait but it remains on social media hold
on so I want to say right now I do want
to tell y'all ah sprouted me a new toe
couple years back here it is you want to
watch let's watch yeah so I had three
toes that were amputated
accident I heard the word for Creative
Miracles and I thought well create a
miracle that I might need I need three
toes to grow back the person next to me
said do you want new toes and I was like
well sure yeah from the toe Factory
and they cried over my foot and I just
prayed on my foot that sounds like a
whole fetish when he said let's see the
progress or if any things happened and
when I did I had to grab the person next
to me and say do you see what I see and
I saw three toes
that were forming and now there's length
to them tonight I can stand on my tippy
toes listen you understand I can stand
on Tiffany show me your foot no I
couldn't do that because I didn't have
those to be on
oh here it is here it is actually
they're about to show it it looks like
oh let's bless the Lord he's Jehovah
Rapha
Lord we praise you yeah that's it go
back to when she's talking why is
everyone freaking out this woman just
sprouted three toes you God did you not
hear this hello this is crazy I love
that they don't even attempt to I mean
if that was me I'd be like look at my
[__] foot yes
the toes are crawling back
I can do all my Tippy Toes that was
incredible uh Casey Mann uh thank you
for that donation that was a great tip I
wish I'd seen that earlier yeah uh so
I'm running a special right now anyone
that donates fifty dollars or more I
will heal I will pledge to pray a few
toes back
although my power is limited to toads
only
um I cannot do anything other than that
by the power of God
thank you only toes
uh okay real quick just looking for the
big ones here there's a 20 one can I get
a birthday shout out from Olivia my
sister uh this is
their name is and also Oliver
so oh wait her sister's name is Olivia
no they're just saying you're okay
sister oh hey sister this is Jesus by
the way oh my God hey Jesus you want to
talk
Jesus be like don't for Zach
thank you Kim that's awesome yeah I love
that uh that's great uh
let's see Sean Avery's retired hockey
player who is much Ruder to bike lane
villains check out his clip montages
okay John Avery will look into that
and check it out well we have a new
rabbit hole here yeah maybe angry bikers
the bike lane Vigilantes yeah
um
let's see if there's any other big ones
I don't want to miss I mean if you want
to sue Aiden Ross do it for the gambling
let's let's get in like I was just
reading the title I'm like what can we
do about this
if we should try to contact some federal
agencies you know what I mean in the Sun
uh Gabby donated 20 said it's my lovely
partner Nate and I's second anniversary
love watching the show together every
week and I'd love to surprise him with
and then it gets cut off but I'm sure
shout out Nate Dog Nate and Gabby
forever and ever
your love will never end you hear me
yeah um anyone who donates 50 right now
this is for men only I can add an extra
inch by God's Powers amen no guarantee
one extra inch
right now this is a only for the next
minute
all claims made on the H3 podcast have
no guarantee
one extra inch you heard it here folks
not actionable
uh amen yeah nick uh donate well donated
25 and said please god Jehovah just one
more inch amen uh he was pretty clear
about it being 50.
but I'll give you a half an inch you
want half an inch I can do that for you
it's just alone Nick Nick mower
one half of an inch by God blessings on
you now this isn't my first now God is
his power is uh as I say
all powerful that being said I can I
can't do more than an inch for you
that's all I got
big differences how you pay it back so
this is uh so who's this guy he's a
former athlete uh what did it say a
hockey player yeah hockey player he's a
former hockey player and a current road
rager okay let's check it out
aren't you a stupid [__] you're a lazy
[__] and you're a stupid [__] I mean
this guy's just doing his job man you
know what I mean like this guy's doing
like taking the trash out
this man ain't got to take [__] from
anybody in my opinion Stan why you just
can't move the [__] truck over you
dumb [__]
this man is a saint by the way this has
this man is the patience
of a cadaver frankly
it does look like there's
quite a bit of shoulder left there to be
fair
even if he can make it work and by the
way actually we have some prayer
requests coming in here Dan uh Derek
runts only gave 49.99 that's not going
to get you anything oh Derek you were
just one penny sure I stuffed my toe the
other day stuck with a short dick and I
wouldn't complain if you gave me an
extra inch too thanks well uh I love to
help you out my brother but you have not
reached the threshold of the of course
the fifty dollars required so uh I
prayed for you but no guarantees but
then another one 49.99 are you guys
crazy or something I said a full inch
man y'all just just Charming me on a
penny
can I get a Fu Samuel from the crew for
a guy who
played me police specifically from
Olivia did we do that one already
that doesn't sound familiar F you said
you Samuel is that what he wants [__]
you Samuel sounds what he wanted like
that [__] you Samuel
oh it's a guy who played her so [__] you
Samuels don't play Garrett okay Garrett
my good old blessed Christian ball
Garrett has given me fifty five oh
dollars and I say a prayer Jesus save me
please bless our brother Garrett whose
penis is mighty but yet Mighty you're
still one extra p uh one extra inch Amen
brother one extra penis one extra a
whole ass penis for my brother it is a
crazy long penis well Garrett said he
would like to get the extra inch to a
random chatter so oh how nice look at
the draw there oh you have to watch him
right now checking your pants right now
the man who won the extra inch I have a
little note in your anus
to look a little magic trip like that
David Blaine type of stuff
um Nathaniel
escaped 70s and I'll take what I can get
Nathaniel I love to help you my brother
take out your penis now
stand up take your penis out brother
and looked down at it and say grow
[Laughter]
I command thee to grow
I'm growing and then your receipt will
be in your anus check your anus for
yourself you got a receipt
yes yeah of course
they're right off growing it it's a
necessary medical procedure it should be
we're church we don't get taxed for it
right all right guys I was just kidding
let's not uh please come on we got a
show to do stop with the fifty dollars
I mean you put out the call
just a gag I can't grow your penis is
there more did I miss any
um
of the penis requests I think you got
all of those yeah so actually I was
there are others but I'm interested in
watching this uh Road rager okay
[Music]
take a [__] on your lawn bro come on
wait Zach yeah call it out yeah I'm a
big bike guy yeah I mean I used to play
hockey in the NHL
[__] yeah celo says can you pray for me
to grow another two inches I've been
hanging around eight inch hard but I'd
really like to hit that 10 inch Mark I
tell you what CeeLo man don't you be
greedy brother
wait they donated 50 and they're asking
for two they want to go from ten they
wanna go from eight to ten well I'm just
more incense that I mean we were pretty
clear that the fifty dollars got you an
inch I'll get I'll tell you what brother
I can give you one inch on the top and
another inch on the stem
ah we can't haggle with magic it's a two
inch by diameter
double and pass it to the next person
but I tell you what brother with them
eight inches you should be dominating
two inches amen let's remove the inches
from his penis and
give it to all yo Nathaniel just donate
again he said it worked yeah no he's got
a solid four we need a we need a write a
a member of the History Podcast recently
reported a miracle took place speed is
grew an entire inch
all right let's watch
[__] out there this is a perfect
example
no you're not gonna give this guy [__] I
want her safe
oh no okay they were unironically saying
that was a good example okay okay right
over here [__] dude
what the [__] you doing what are you
[__] stupid you almost [__] killed
this is like such New York [__] what are
you [__] stupid Hey idiot greatest
city in the world but this is psycho man
I'm not trying to catch any of this [__]
outside that guy these people are just
doing their job you [__] idiot what
did you do to your hair oh come on
I knew you were a good ass
cigarettes is he drunk from a [__]
block away I just knew it was coming
dude this guy is this guy is troubled
so you mad about that I am you're mad
what are you gonna do
I'm not gonna do anything [__] no I'm
just not gonna give you a cigarette wow
you're the biggest [__] [__] that
might be true
Jesus okay okay this is New York that's
some new as a New York minute
things can go down holy crap all right I
don't feel bad for that guy anymore
There's No Business stopping here
it's really just unbelievable
watch her wobble while she gets on the
bike here
a break bro she's like an old lady she's
like a straight up old lady
get the [__] out of the road you old
hack
this guy's a demon
bro it's my day off on Saturday you
can't park your bike here like this I
mean it's directly on the sidewalk dude
come on you know I'm trying to do it hit
me with a little pound here atta boy
yeah bro yeah
attaboy
I'm not loving this guy yeah
everyone's saying this is CTE in full
effect right yeah yo
what kind of parking job is this with
the bike
I'm just curious
this guy's just like he's like a big ass
dude you know hockey players are crazy
ass they are getting fired they're
psycho
yeah this guy's just looking to fight
someone I get the feeling
cruising around drunk chain smoking
yelling at people Apparently one of our
mods just sent me uh this guy's
Wikipedia page and he has a whole
controversies and bullying section oh I
would never guess that uh let me just
read you I won't read the details just
the top lines here uh leukemia comment
there's a section for his leukemia
comment uh heckling incident uh sloppy
seconds comment wait what you gonna do
are you gonna Heckle people with
leukemia the feud would try again I
don't know the details I'm just wait
read me the leukemia one okay the
leukemia comment in November 2007 Howard
Berger a reporter for Toronto radio
station blah blah blah stated that an
unnamed Ranger player had accused Avery
of commenting about Toronto Maple Leafs
player John Blake's battle with leukemia
prior to the pregame confrontation
between Avery and Toronto's Darcy Tucker
Avery who denied the allegation received
the NHL maximum 2500 fine
that doesn't sound that interesting yeah
heckling incident sloppy seconds Feud
with John
torterella Tortorella restraining other
order and other bullying incidents
criminal mischief trial yeah this guy
this guy's trouble
could never guess
criminal mischief
why would you park it like this out here
like this this man's out here feeling
himself too bullying people but there's
people that are trying to walk into the
subway and into the store are you I mean
it's not bad not that yeah it's not that
big of a deal
hey there
how you doing I'm good man what's up
morning I'm just wondering why you're
such a [__] [__] and you had to
park here okay this dude is for sure
drunk at like 8 A.M right now
hey I'm just wondering why you're such a
[__] [__] and you had to park here
[Applause]
let's go around [__] [__]
you got sleepy eyes there should I just
ride around you all right he's just a
dick uh you know I've seen it enough
there it is the bike lane is Serious
Business watch your ass in that bike
lane in New York City not safe for
anybody I again I genuinely do have
somewhat of sympathy because I mean
people do do dangerous [__] around bikes
all the time and I I was a bike rider
for years I rode my bike all growing up
to and from school every day
um starting in like elementary school
and I rode my bike a lot as an adult too
and yeah it can be it can be sketchy out
there so but
I don't think you're really doing the
community in many favors but just
screaming and calling everyone a [__]
[__] all the time I don't think
you're ingratiating them to your to your
cause you know so um
we have time for
uh another segment so we have
uh the Sydney Sweeney PowerPoint
oh yes we do and then we also have
Matthew McConaughey's Art of Living
which I can't wait to get to uh so they
took down the video The Art of Living
they took it down what it had so many
views I know I'm very curious why uh it
may have been their plan to only keep it
up for a few days because it is
weird marketing thing so I mean there
were some re-uploads but of just like
some sections but um I don't know if
we're just gonna do one more thing I
would say let's do the let's do the
PowerPoint Olivia you feeling oh Olivia
ready for the swedney
Sydney Sweeney
are we ready I'm ready all right let's
go so Hello Olivia I'm not familiar with
this drama at all I know who Sydney
Sweeney is she's the blonde girl uh from
Euphoria yes
uh uh uh loved her in that show
fantastic actress fantastic
um okay so how do we want to do this do
you want to do the flips and all I can
yeah I can open the PowerPoint
okay
brought to you by
[Music]
e
so here it is you tell me when you want
me to do next slide beautiful
so
this is a mess
Sydney Sweeney Glenn Powell Gigi Paris
Jonathan devino
next slide I don't know who GG or
Jonathan are I'll teach you okay thank
you
okay players Sydney Sweeney 25 years old
she is an actress
she came up big time as all those
Euphoria people did
I mean didn't they all get like super
famous yeah they all like well Zendaya
was already famous from her Disney show
but she's like I think well yeah she
skyrocketed past that now she's
Spider-Man everything but all the actors
on that show got like crazy crazy
opportunities for real all right next
Sydney Sweeney is engaged to Jonathan
Divino who is 38. they've been together
for five years oh older guys yeah
interesting he uh his family has a pizza
Dynasty oh he's Rich yeah he's based in
Chicago what what dynasty
he's got pizza money he's got pizza
money okay girl oh
okay Mr Pizza Mr Pizza yeah anyone out
there eating Mr Pizza
all right next
slide
oh this is Glenn Powell and also an
older gentleman also an older gentleman
34. next
who is he just he's an actor
he is dating Gigi Paris she's a model
they've been together for three years
so these are serious relationships and
she's pretty age-appropriate for him
she's 30. right right true right
so Sydney was recently cast in a film
with Glenn Powell Gigi's boyfriend so
Sydney posted this on Instagram to
announce that they were going to
Australia to film this this movie
together Glenn the boy the fellow actor
commented Sydney and Sydney and Gigi
Glenn's girlfriend commented on Sydney's
post with celebratory emojis so
everybody loves each other it seems like
everybody's working together Good Vibes
Good Vibes we're still yeah we're still
in the United States okay okay okay okay
so then the year begins and
they go to Australia to begin Sydney and
Sydney Sydney in Sydney with Glenn
trouble so as the movie begins filming
they begin to release little little
moments on set it looks like they're
having a lot of fun like this one Glenn
posted a photo of him in that box Sydney
looking up dreamily at him yeah yeah the
caption is Hot Box Sydney flirtatious
right a little box Sydney posted it
herself on her Twitter she reposted
Glenn's Instagram and she wrote HotBox
people were like okay cute they're
becoming friends now they're doing a
rom-com together right and so they're it
makes sense they're the couple in this
rom-com okay
everything's good now steamy steamy
so he posted this photo of them together
yes oh and he said Hot Box he said
HotBox
so it just seems like they're becoming
friends was he calling himself hot I
think so and then Sydney reposting it
she's like yeah hot box
it's a little corny of him to say that I
don't know that I agree I don't think I
like him very much I don't think I like
this whole story me neither already I
don't know you already hate him kind of
yeah absolutely so next
these are from the movie these are
photos that the paps took of them
filming so this everybody was like Oh
yay this movie looks awesome they look
in love and like great actors okay
memories
memories are being made this is the cast
that Sydney laying coincidentally on her
co-stars lap which isn't a big deal
but it's interesting it is something to
take note of in the full context of
things
certainly we'll see at right right now
no red flags yeah the hot box thing
would make me uncomfortable I would I
would note it I wouldn't say anything
necessarily no but I I would notice that
I'd be like why did that girl just post
that photo of my boyfriend and like say
oh that was his joke or if I was so many
Todds uh you were in the pizza Dynasty
yeah if I was the pizza money you'd be
like why'd you call him hot mm-hmm yeah
oh man I haven't seen him shirtless this
is a photo that was taken behind the
scene
set
so interesting
looks like they're having fun what is
the context of this photo there is on
set it looks like he's like lifting
before a shirtless scene or something
who took the photo where'd we get the
someone and crew and where was it posted
this was surfaced as sets from their
movie like photos from set photos they
put this out yeah it's like PR
um you'll see a lot of this is like
is it so blatant that this is all PR or
is this so messy that it can't be PR
okay interesting as of right now it's
still clean memories I agree
these are in between I wouldn't like
this photo right all of these photos
you're about to go through are from in
between takes so this is not what they
were filming
listen I know body language they're
they're they're too they're close their
shoulders are touching this is
flirtation yep there's no question about
it I think so too if I'm one of their
significant others again I'm not
necessarily gonna say anything yet but
I'm getting uncomfortable and I went to
school for theater like
been in plays where there are romantic
counterparts right you become close you
become friends you don't necessarily
kiss behind the scenes well I would hope
not right I would too you know that's
not part of the job that's not part of
the job
quick question
where are those feet coming up from
there's someone yeah there's another guy
there's hands here there are more photos
from this
if you uh oh that was covered by your
yeah on the screen it was covered so
it's just like this mysterious foot
sticking out and I'll tell you what I'll
tell you what this guy he's not that
funny he doesn't look that funny and
she's laughing way too [__] harder
how do you know I know that dude ain't
funny bro how do you know because he's
got maybe he's hysterical no he's not
sure oh my God Ethan is right now this
one now she not that funny right because
nobody's that funny unless you like them
Dan
do you know what I'm saying you make me
laugh that hard sometimes oh
what are you trying to say
what's the implication the implication
is very clear my friend me and you
together forever you guys should go to
the beach but do you know what I'm
saying when there's two people together
like this
this is this is a flirtatious laugh I
know it I know it I think so too still
if that were my boyfriend I would be
like okay he's this is his job let's see
what happens yeah
okay that's behind the scenes
bro now why why she's touching
him like
one touches someone they're flirting
with I would say
shaving her boobs all are up and yeah he
they're swimming in the ocean there
could be seaweed that she's like wiping
off or something wiping her boobs off on
him I mean you know oh there's seaweed
on my boobs can I wipe them on you yeah
seaweed some sort of like uh crustacean
stuff okay if I'm if I'm with one of
these people and I see this photo I
might be saying something yeah I would
say something I might be like what's
going on here be like hey girls that
part of the movie or no were you guys
filming uh yeah was this uh tell me yeah
you know because I'm trying to do the
math listen we've been together five
years three years just tell me if I need
to move on the next one is pretty crazy
okay we're getting worse oh my God
that's a couple that's a couple how do
we know they're not filming he's
penetrating because they weren't perhaps
the paps didn't take picks during
filming this was in between takes this
is them having a fun wait okay hold on
they're on set they're on set but these
are in between I thought this was just a
fun no so that guy's the foot that man
was in the film okay that makes it a
little less worse yeah we're not we're
not to bad places yet they hang out not
on set soon
but I might
next slide I might go to Australia if
those photos yeah yeah yeah so we know
that Gigi went to Australia because next
slide
whoa
she posted on her Instagram she
geotagged Australia she posted making
the most of my last day in Australia
with that film by Thomas but she didn't
post with Glenn or Sydney
she she was there though was she in the
same town as them she she went to
Australia to visit Glenn on set how do
you know that because they were seen
together but she didn't post with them
okay okay and is she someone who posts
like a lot of yeah she's in she's like
an influencer okay okay
interesting so we know that she went to
Australia she then left Australia she
says it's been a week yeah
she's been through some stuff it seems
like that now and a heavy week for her
so then
cast to bonding photos start to surface
people are like Sydney's putting
together like such nice activities for
the whole cast and crew why do they
think Sydney's doing it yeah why isn't
he doing all that she's doing all that
work she's the actress not just for him
well you'll see so this is the first
time
photos surface people were quick to
point out that that is Glenn's jacket
that she's wearing which is like maybe
it was cold sure whatever it gets cold
in Australia
hold on it gets nippy the jacket moves
is flirtatious I agree
with my boyfriend in Australia and I
left feeling possibly insecure and then
I saw the girl I felt insecure about
wearing his coat
let me put it this way if you're walking
with a dude who you're not interested at
all
you're not taking his coat no you're
gonna say no thanks you'll be I'm fine
if you're shivering cold you there's
plenty other dudes you get codes from
yeah
they're with the whole crew there's an
entire she's not taking the coach unless
she likes it she wants to smell like Kim
exactly she wants to smell it she wants
to feel his warmth from his body yeah
this is
crew neck
I mean that one is [__] cool so yeah
someone says I'm baffled we're still
live it feels like so long I'm with you
although it's been what probably like
three hours no 2 40. yeah 240. that's
short for us well lately our our Norm is
like three and a half hours man yeah
I've noticed yep most people get shorter
we do more content and longer I don't
know how it works
so the next slide are more photos from
that day
oh my God I feel like where's her hand
justify that where's her hand in this
photo because I imagine it's on his leg
pretty high up no have you I mean those
roller coaster seats they're real small
you don't really have an option
this is a reach guys we're at the top of
a tour bus Dan oh that's a tour bus yeah
oh those are small too I guess okay we
can sit still okay hold the phone hold
the phone I think the question of where
is her hand is quite compelling yeah
because the body language the again if
you want to take a photo with your homie
you can lean over the head touching the
hand across is I agree that's that's
romantic it feels it's beyond flirtation
it could just be a hug though it could
nah just be a hug no no no no women
don't take pictures like this with all
my boys all the time we're only at 18.
you wrap around your homies go hit the
head yeah we've got about 20 more slides
for me to convince you okay
okay so more cast bonding but that's
Glenn's family in Sydney oh at the zoo
sometimes you just go to a zoo day with
the entire family of your co-stars yes
yeah I know that's but the rest of the
cast and the crew weren't here today
so Glenn's fam yeah
who's visiting from Australia
they're visiting from Australia because
he's American uh-huh
where did they travel from America what
state
Austin Texas so it's a pretty that's a
very long play right
they came a long way yeah and he said
he said to his family who traveled God
what's that flight from Austin to I mean
let me look for you to Sydney it doesn't
get much longer it's got to be like 18
hours
thank you Jay Audi for the donut 15
hours 45 minutes dude am I like a
[__] genius or something yeah maybe
literally what I said so the family
clearly was like wait no no YouTube
YouTube I want to get YouTube feeding
the giraffe so this precious time of his
family right he says no I I want to
bring
Sydney and look how she's like oh yeah I
love his
yeah
she's mine she's my best friend in the
world
if you go to the next one there's more
on Easter they stop it they're together
I'm done yeah right so on Easter they
climbed the Sydney Bridge they're
together and everyone knows it and then
his mom posted this day on set with his
nephew and niece holding Sydney's hand
and her like showing them nah I feel
like that feels romantic to me I'm done
however he has a girlfriend she's
engaged
whoa have you ever heard of oh you
missed that part
we're both in like Madness relationships
this is important Sydney
has a five-year long uh boyfriend
they're engaged they got engaged last
year yeah not for long homie here has
been in a three-year relationship
and they are double crossing them yeah
and fam is involved
have you guys never heard of the method
okay this is Method act no no Strasbourg
would not approve oh yeah
hey Sydney you want to do some method
acting tonight at my place is not
interested in this rom-com I promise you
okay interesting
so cast bonding this was also posted on
uh Glenn's family's page if you it says
on that Instagram of them in the kitchen
Easter with the fam with a heart no
if I'm Sydney's uh fiance I'm like
if I'm Glenn's fiance I mean a
girlfriend I would lose my mind I think
you're like what do you mean with the
family
I'm not there
it's all bad it's all bad it's rumored
that when she left that's when they
split though
it hasn't been announced yet but it's
rumored that when she left Australia
Australia to get dumped that's [__]
cold that's the speculation That's cold
blooded brother yeah so then after the
movie wrapped they were photographed
hugging at the airport together
we just filmed the whole movie together
whatever I'm letting you know so great
working with you I'm giving you I'm
giving you the data points they went to
the airport they [__] yeah that's what
I think too we're about to get music do
not have jumping to conclusion Dan you
do not have the no no no no no no
emotional maturity yeah
you guys are the ones being immature I'm
laying out given circumstances we
haven't even started the media frenzy we
haven't even gotten to cinemacon which
is people are saying Gigi and the pizza
guy need to get together I think so too
is a pizza pie I got that uh what's the
name of it again
caught me Mr Pizza so
next
rumors are swirling never better oh
people are like how does gigi feel about
all of this because I know that he has a
girlfriend she went to Coachella she
posted never better with a wavy Emoji so
people are like oh okay I see why are
they why is she keeping it a secret if
they broke up that I don't care you'll
she doesn't anymore she's just waving
low yeah she's waving hello hi fans top
comments or he left this girl for Sydney
the most gorgeous Yeehaw girl I ever did
see
I mean they're both I think they're both
beautiful we don't need them we don't
need to split hairs on that who's
prettier
but just letting you know people are
talking about it this goes viral so they
go to cinemacon this is the day before
um cinemacon begins they release this
video of them
just like for PR for the film they're
hyping up the film exactly they're not
even on set like this wasn't a part of
the movie this was at Cinema before you
don't you're still working until release
day
Hey Sydney go get on his lap and then
lay down across it the photographer this
man is giving me homelander but yeah
that was his idea for sure by the way I
don't like him I don't like him neither
next that's pretty sussy
cinemacon
a normal PR stuff these are photos of
them on the carpet this is fun oh well
it's fine but are they holding hands
here they do seem to be
um pretty close to each other if you go
to the next slide this is fine this is
fine this is fine this I'm wondering
what's happening right the next slide I
have three separate clips that I need us
to watch okay okay interesting love
Australia
um I guess you gotta kick up the volume
a little for me Zach
we love Australia it's like hard to have
a bad time in Australia we I hate him
yeah yeah he's like I'm [__] hot and
I've got and I'm handsome she's like
it's so fun in Australia I loved kissing
you in Australia that's what it feels
like he's a badass
it might be it's a rage it might be he's
a bad apple
um we did like so many activities uh
Sydney was like our social chair we had
an activity every weekend that everybody
went out and did you know but I don't
know about you but I feel like this is
like not only do we go for the hardar
which is really really fun
he's talking about our R rated
hold the phone she says it twice by the
way in this video the hard R yeah uh
we're having a Linus Tech tips moment
not hard R hold on roll that back
edit activity every weekend that
everybody went out and did oh but I
don't know about you but I feel like
this is like not only do we go for the
hard R which is really really fun but
it's also like so he's talking about the
rating yes so this man was like I've got
rated R with you girl
this movie is rated R it's very adult
I'm sure there's lots of intimacy yeah
he emphasized we went for the hard arm
again about the hard R in this clip okay
chills maybe it's just okay I know right
we've got it how hard is the r yeah you
know not to be confused with like the
n-word never
and it looks like neither of them even
thought about it
they were like oh yeah you go for the
heart R we did in Australia that's your
privilege
pull it back it was the last time you
saw like a hard R ROM stop it bro
stop saying that no one wants a hard or
wrong when's the last time you said the
hard off
hard or rom-com that's big and it's
cinematic it's a hard R it's like
basically NC-17 I mean yeah it can't get
right here see this is standard this is
industry lingo you all just aren't
Hollywood enough to understand
again I don't like him talking about how
hot he is I don't like when he does that
yeah
so that's just one okay moving on
it would be
whatever I don't know I don't know
somewhere outside
what's your perfect day I'll tell you
I'll tell you what was really
interesting is watching Sydney visit the
rugby locker room in Australia
that's not a perfect date
that's not a perfect day
come on Dan I thought that was serious
these [__] are as guilty as MJ
yeah
I didn't say it thank you full
Redemption
oh [__] has risen he has he's up he's up
he's up I'm going to the bathroom
thank you for your word don't worry if
the MJ people come for you I got your
back brother yeah
truth will set you free
yeah no that's not a perfect day an
entire rugby team slid into her DMS in
record time he is funny he's so funny
I don't like him at all yeah I hate him
they I think would be some good food
some good laughter and just a quiet
peaceful place I don't know yeah yeah
everywhere everywhere we went in
Australia we like went out with
everybody but it's like a oh really you
know there's not one everywhere is the
perfect date in Australia right living
on Bandai shooting on the cliffs it was
amazing
all right
stop it one last clip this is just them
having sex I'm assuming yeah this is
their sex tape
whole experience was absolutely
incredible
we we get to literally take over
Australia it's like this movie is the
like the tourism Board of Australia just
gave us carte blanche on anything we
wanted
so we could do anything it was so much
fun there was one there was one day
where we were literally it was one day
when we took a bunch of trash out into
the coral the Great Coral Reef and we
just dumped it for fun didn't let us do
anything we could do anything we could
do anything dude I just we just took oil
barrels and just dumped it on the coral
reef it was awesome I went and shot like
30 kangaroos dude I was sick we just
left them there man it was awesome most
people weren't even dead they were just
Bleeding Out
it was so fun we could do anything it
was crazy I even killed a few Aboriginal
people yeah nobody cares crazy
we could do anything we can do anything
yeah
uh took over the Sydney Opera House and
that was yeah what's with the tiny ass
Mike oh bro what the [__] why is it it's
because it's an interview on the carpet
so they must have been like here for our
Tick Tock what is this an interview for
ads yeah
they're just being goofy
and Barack Obama watch this film the
scene yes he does that's pretty
memorable and Glenn landed a helicopter
and jumped out of it it's really cool
there we go and that was just improv I
just didn't even the helicopter wouldn't
even plan you know I don't I'm not mad
at Sydney for some reason it's like he's
older and you know he's like 35 I mean
come on man I mean to be fair Sydney
wasn't really publicly as
talkative as he was I feel like like on
the carpet he was the one who was like
we you know Sydney the locker room
Honestly though Sydney did really [__]
her boyfriend five years and engage oh
yeah they both yeah I mean that's that
is and there's more that's
also that's like lifelong I feel like uh
that'll give you a complex for life
he cheated on she's yeah she's working
she's at her job and you really have
when you have like a hot actor actress
significant other and they're doing
rom-coms you really have to trust them
and then you know to Ultimate betrayal
man
sad I haven't seen any betrayal yet
okay fair enough
so what do we have the nickname
a quote from the convention is I love
when she calls me Top Gun because he was
in Top Gun Glenn Powell on Sydney
Sweeney's nickname you love when she
calls you that he loves he loves when
she calls nobody else nobody's ever
called me Top Gun because that's a movie
I'm famous for
that is big break he was in Top Gun yeah
I've never noticed him before he was in
Top Gun
I love when when when I call him Top Gun
so then the next slide I just included
this because I was like interesting
parallels no huh just to like take a
peek at not to name them what's the
parallel so you know the Brad and
Angelina Story how like he cheated on
Jennifer Aniston when he was filming Mr
Elizabeth Smith I didn't know that he
cheated oh well Angelina and Jolie met
on set for Mr and Mrs Smith and they
were not together they were not dating
oh my God and then they got married and
had the world that's the dumbest movie
to have an affair over
okay interesting so then
after
you just mute yourself oops after the
first day Gigi unfollows Sydney on
Instagram she still follows Glenn at
this point but she unfollowed Gigi
that's the first step Dan the unfollow
uh Instagram it has been having all
kinds of bugs it's a bug that's not
reliable in any way I mean sometimes
what if um
what if uh Sydney um
uh soft blocked her blocked her and then
unblocked to get rid of the follow why
would you do that
she's jealous she's jealous
interesting because the next day she
posts a breakup Oh no you're worth and
on to the next she says girl your next
one's gonna be better I agree
the both of y'all move forward with your
head up you got pizza money and her
she don't want to be with homelander
that [__] the top comments that she has
left up are yes girl you deserve better
hashtag team Gigi and I can't imagine
how much he was probably gaslighting
Gigi in private it's just for a film
babe all these people speculating that's
true that's what I'm saying is the the
traumatic part of this like it's just a
film it's just a film you know what I
mean yeah um
so then she unfollowed Glenn after she
posted okay okay
and we're three years Sydney now clean
up the pieces are we ready what about
what about Divino what about our Pizza
Guy
what's his pizza called again
what about Mr Pizza what about
Mississippi I've never been in the pizza
category
well TMZ after cinemacon releases this
Sydney
dating Glenn Powell she's still engaged
her damn this is your phone never mind
my TMZ always gets it hold on never mind
knowledge yeah whatever the [__] hold on
this is very interesting yeah so sources
with direct knowledge told TMZ Sydney is
still living with Jonathan all is well
between them and they are still engaged
we're told that Glenn and Sydney are not
dating hold the [__] phone
he was photographed the same day as this
outside of her house walking her dog I
wrote cook kidding and then new news
dropped the next day he was seen with
bags leaving her house oh with a dog bed
though
and then on Friday night they were seen
in public for the first time since the
film Sydney's not wearing her engagement
ring which she did before filming
um if you go to the next one you'll see
the TMZ reported they didn't look happy
he goes to reach out for her and she
basically says no
I mean okay this is hard to tell what's
going on here people think she's Saving
Face
they think they're not together anymore
and she's uh
doing this pup for like publicity why
would he agree yeah why would he agree
to that I don't know no that'd be like
oh and also I mean a lot of uh fatty
foods in Australia maybe you know the
ring it was getting uncomfortable she
needs to get it resized Maybe
[Music]
this guy looks like people excuse me
down
excuse me what she's getting fat
I was just you know it's it's an
engagement ring so it's probably new
maybe it was never the right size and
then you know it was uncomfortable
that's fair here's my question no big
deal no big deal if this media
storm happened and people were
speculating you weren't with your
boyfriend anymore you had cheated on
your boyfriend and then you were seen in
public with him for the first time
would you publicly not hold his hand
when he reached for it
I don't know that that's what happened
from these photos okay you have to see
the video yeah I'd have to is there a
video no TMZ just reported that they
didn't do a very good job looking like a
happy couple I mean who knows what they
even like pretend I mean go to the next
photo that's them like getting in the
car they're having a great night okay
she doesn't have her engagement ring on
this is real this is quite a Twist
though I know yeah I was surprised when
all of this stuff came so this guy
definitely broke up and it's definitely
because of Sydney yeah so here's the
options is maybe he caught feelings and
she was kind of like teasing him a
little bit leading him on that's
possible that's possible the other
possibility is maybe Sydney and pizza
boy have a open relationship maybe
they're engaged which would be kind of
fire if she ruined his life and then was
like all right peace all right see you
later see you at the premiere
but yeah that's all the info we have for
now
and a little um how much is this pizza
guy how much is he worth yeah
I never heard of uh
Mr Pizza sounds
doesn't sound like good pizza
Mr Pizza Mr Mr Pizza
four million oh he's okay I'm gonna say
broke but oh he's poor yeah I don't say
poor but he ain't no papa John
um who uh who's uh between Glenn and uh
the other guy uh who's taller good
question Dan
very good question Dan
we can settle this all they both seem
pretty tall uh to be fair Glenn Powell
height Jonathan Divino it says one six
six foot five eight who's five eight
Jonathan devino what Pizza Guys five
eight that's what Drescher says but look
at them next to each other and he's fine
he's little there ain't no way that
guy's five eight look how far back he is
Sydney
Sweeney Sydney's five three oh my God
she's like tiny what the f oh okay well
um but a drama update the Clara do you
remember the one who had the affair with
Shakira's ex-husband
no no oh well I cried I wanted to go I
kind of I remember that happening
um she cheated on him with his soccer
coach right in the jam the the jam gave
it away right or the jelly you right
right that was the joke she found the
jelly and he doesn't like it Shakira's
ex was cheated on by his mistress who
cheated on him with his own soccer coach
can you believe that Ethan I know
all right sorry I just thought I got
that to the end I was trying to Crunch
the numbers on this honestly I was lost
in thought
we're obviously going to know pretty
soon if they're together I think so you
know what after seeing this I actually
think that
Sydney said uh bye bye to
Glenn yeah interesting I think she's out
and I think see I you know I've been
arguing that nothing was going on I can
go along maybe Glenn like you said
caught some feelings but Cindy I think
professional she's like Glenn what are
you doing we're acting this is a
romantic comedy maybe listen I don't
blame I think he caught feelings maybe I
mean she was hanging out with his family
it was his and she was sending all the
wrong messages yeah
I you know shh I feel like she was
overly flirty with him
feelings oh please and then but you saw
the Jack I mean it looked like they were
together
you know what I mean the water this
isn't a case of like wrongfully saying a
girl is flirty I think it really looked
like they were acting romantic I totally
see him Catching Feelings yeah which is
why he broke up with his girlfriend go
ahead sorry Kim I just think that Glenn
cheated but he banged the giraffe at the
zoo that's
what happened
that's why I see that draft's tongue
it's all over him
yeah it was
uh shout out to Joshua who's in the
hospital you got this brother
let's go Joshua
I'll pray for you I'll pray for you
Joshua I'll grow you a toe and I'll give
you an inch anything beyond that is out
of my power amen
God is great
[__] man I actually want to know what
happened something happened for sure I
agree because he broke up with his
girlfriend I mean as soon as I know I'll
let you all know
I'll have mine Mr Pizza wide open
it's very interesting
very [__] interesting
what do we think about the pizza guy do
we like him
I mean I don't know much about him
besides pizza money and Sydney oh I have
an important update for y'all that I
just spot in the chat
all right let me confirm though I think
I saw it
Alfredo where are you going
okay okay let's take a look the Met Gala
is happening right now is she wearing it
I don't see it no what what is that
she's not wearing an engagement ring
hold on that is that's on a ring finger
on the right side yeah that's her ring
finger what no no what her ring fingers
second ones
this finger
this one
both are Barons oh sure you're right
it's not a ring finger yeah no that's
her middle finger yeah her ring and her
pointer
it's her middle finger with the ring
she's not wearing a she's not wearing an
engagement ring yeah so she was wearing
an engagement ring she was before the
movie yes what the [__]
she was seen with her engagement ring
when she was flying back from Australia
but not when she was with him
TMZ reported when they said they're not
dating it said sources with direct
knowledge say that they're still they're
still engaged and that she was not
without her ring I trust the reporting
in TMZ they don't get things wrong
they're trusted news yeah they are quite
good they are quite good
well I'll say this I don't know what's
going on although I know that homelander
took a fat l oh wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute what oh this is
this was last year's Met Gala I'm sorry
hold on we need fake news Dan what the
[__] so that works in our favor though
she was right she wasn't wearing it last
year oh that's interesting she doesn't
always wear oh wait so hold on we need
we need and last year she was happily
engaged well they got married they got
engaged in 2022. here this is no this is
the new one
this is today
three minutes ago page six let's get it
let's get a little close-up
zoom in on those Fingers Dan
oh
that looks like an engagement ring a fat
to me a diamond yep on the engagement
finger Kim's son good image hey girl
oh Cam's got the receipts here it is
here she is that's not her ring finger
wait this is her ring finger bro yeah
you wear it on your left yeah on your
left I don't think people really ah man
I don't know I've only heard of left I
heard right means something else really
what is right you don't want to know
wait what does right finger mean
something's okay so uh
ah sheesh I don't know that that looks
like an engagement ring the brim is like
too Saucy it's like a sauce dish it's
like a little teacup hmm
Mr Pizza it's a Mr Pizza right right
baby I got you this pizza ring hey hmm I
don't know what to believe other photos
of her she's wearing it on her left hand
but I know that this is an event so
maybe that's why but
she has worn it on her left hand before
now I'm really just listening if I'm her
I don't want to be ambiguous about it
everyone's speculating you want to prep
your man right and and the the paps
photos too I feel like if you want to
make a statement
make a statement don't just walk next to
him
ask chai TBT what does it mean if the
engagement ring is on the right hand
because I never I when I wore a ring I
don't wear a ring because I just don't
like the feeling of it but I was all
over the place
uh in Eastern Europe South America and
Scandinavian countries it's customary to
wear the engagement ring on the right
hand for example in Russia Ukraine and
Colombia people often wear their
engagement rings on the right hand well
that's not applicable from any of those
places
uh she's she's like white as [__] she's
like she's like hella White
she's like Civil War white you know what
I mean
she's like
she like that good 1860 why
I will say her Met Gala outfit this year
is awesome you like it beautiful yeah I
I guess I
yeah it's pretty it doesn't it's not
like crazy or anything I'm a fan of the
black bows
the black bow yeah there's one like near
the train of the dress and one on her
head
okay Queen
make it happen Okay Queen but
okay so so we have there's no conclusion
no unfortunately
does ELA wear her ring I think she does
I think she wears yeah I think she does
but she's into the hardware you know
what I mean
I'm seeing that she's from Spokane
remember her family is the one that oh
the Maga family right I was about to say
Spokane wait we're Spokane Washington
it's the capital of Washington but it's
I was like what it's like a lot of white
supremacists that's what I was gonna
tell you brother that that that right
there he's like yeah yeah last year when
it was her mom's birthday photos
surfaced and like people were wearing
blue lives matter shirts Maga hats
that's what I'm saying
she like that good Plantation wise you
know what I'm saying
Let's do let's let's cap this episode
off by asking the audience ask the
audience so what what exactly would be
the question I guess we know that
homelander [__] off
do they share an authentic off-screen
kiss
or how about just more broadly
do they have enough days or was there
yeah did they have an affair I mean
let's cut to the chase did they have an
affair
yes or no
here we go
I trust our community there's a lot of
smart people right now I know I know the
notes there's a lot of smart people are
out there and like you all listened a
lot you know so so here's the thing I'm
on the fence either between Tia Dan it's
not that serious
just blew up on me again I'm stuck
between yes
is not the capital
yes yes people are very up in arms about
that I'm gonna say yes though all caps
spamming holy [__] dude sorry for this
misinformation no okay everybody calm
down
there's 91 yes
holy [__] that is like a blowout I mean
the rest of the internet thinks so too
it's not just the H3 pod everybody is
like I think they did it so how does the
pizza guy I think the question was
unclear this is a bad poll stop it's a
bad poll Dan this is a great pool for
once in your life yeah literally this is
a perfect Bowl yeah yes
look at this hole Dan that's a great
pull okay so what is the pizza guy
what does Mr Pizza make of this well I
wonder if
I mean some people forgive others if
that did happen maybe he would want to
work past it I don't know
if you had a pizza Dynasty would you
want to order that's a big [__] ask
man I wouldn't call it a dynasty I read
that both places closed down so I don't
know if it's really a dynasty some
dynasties come to an end wait Mr Pizza
closed yeah that's what I read he went
out of business oh no wonder she's a
deadbeat I'll double check that's a
deadbeat
it's Mr Pizza mister mister
Pizza
uh Mr Pizza like m-i-s-t two stores
isn't a dynasty
Papa John has a dynasty a legacy all
right
another Fallen like Fallen Legacy
just like is this the right place Mr
m-i-s-t-a Pizza Mr Pizza sounds like it
to me
well they have a YouTube channel
well it seems to me that the consensus
among the audiences is pretty
pretty pretty aligned there he himself
has worked as a rest Frontier and was
listed in crane Chicago business the
owner of two Chicago restaurants Mr
Pizza and Pompeii Express which have
both closed he's a loser
this man opened a restaurant it's not
even a chain called Mr his family his
family also owns fourth round and final
Bell Pizza
I don't get it man I don't know I don't
this guy's on the weed he's he's trying
to he's juggling Pizza points it's not
Dynasty like what is it when like
there's like a short Gap he's a feudal
Lord in the rulership yeah it's like uh
the pizza into regnum
I think it's called um chapter seven
chapter seven bankruptcy
okay well I I usually await updates if
we get any yeah no Absolutely I'll be
all over it until here yes dude I mean
here's someone says
Meadow says Gigi broke up with Glenn and
pizza guy forgave Sydney that's what I
think kind of
like maybe it's possible because pizza
guy like I said he's like a he's like a
he's got nothing going on how's he gonna
top that
and now he's broke he's got family
businesses she's probably making a
killing
I mean pizza guy's like honey whatever
Gigi on the other hand it's all
happening for Gigi
[__] you Glenn
Glenn Beck asked Gigi has a bright
future I know it
all right it's probably gonna suck too
the rom-con
oh yeah the movies oh yeah
that's gonna suck I'm seeing that movie
the day it comes out yeah okay girl
bring a report will do all right guys
listen up
what a fun day we've had huh lots of UPS
lots of downs lots of flat helmets
but overall
hopefully it more up
I had fun this was it was definitely an
episode of the H3 podcast oh for sure
that we can say for sure
for sure
foreign
members get an episode tomorrow see you
next Tuesday I will be live for members
so okay I'm moving Tuesday episodes to
three so that I can pick up Theodore
from school
okay
so that'll be we'll be going live at
three what the [__] that was so fun it's
so long ago it's like a little shrimp
when he said that that's great
so I'll see you guys tomorrow members
and thank you everybody Wednesday we'll
be back with another Slammer
and I can't wait for Crowder to put out
a video come on please please please
please
Crowder's speeding man he's crowd and he
bitched out
but we'll see
the pressure's gonna amount he's got to
do it
anyway guys have a fan a great night a
beautiful night
and I'll see members tomorrow everyone
else on Wednesday what can I say
I love y'all see you next time
[Music]
foreign